oh right you guys in there it's probably
the least most important platform
anyways listen there we go a slander
later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Lourdes Lourdes what's going on
Sound Check sound check me an attic in a
building to make sure y'all can hear us
good had a little issue with mixer I
don't know what's going on mixer Lords
I'm sorry like we're gonna restream to
you today twitch you guys a good
Facebook you guys are good let me know
if you guys can hear us others Inc but
up fastback and LG what Oh eternal
should die my man what's going on let me
know if you I can hear what's good all
can't daddy my man def scented UK stand
up what's up I think let them know I'm
taking any bro what's up guys so crispy
what's going on sure who my bear Frodo I
can play the Frodo in a minute let's go
to oh that's what's up man turning a
chat like I said a little issue with mix
of the day we don't know what's going on
waiting on King waiting on soft you know
saying about the mute King when he come
in cuz he's coming with a theme song
night trying to get copyright strike how
loaded dim in the noisy a day I got you
yeah whatever gonna get hit with my
coffee I sure cuz the key no I got my
reading I got mommy but Freddy but he
pull up cuz I know what he do we we we
should be in a little bit just get all
got we waited for the king in a song you
know is it dizzy what's going on
gene what's going on mostly Martinez I
was going over that the Hat look at
crispy baby teespring that calm I'm
feeling it
see you guys in a few minutes you wait
no the rest of them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got a mute for that massage it is frog
say why you talk to him you saw that you
had to give us a high 60 I gotta get
y'all ready that was hilarious yo you
went on that you want to net we gonna be
here so we wait though the King if you
think I was miss 16 way to the King
pull-up he come up with a soul brat
what's going on what's going on slo-mo
scream what's going on we're just
waiting on king of sob I don't know
what's going on with them you know
saying but we see yeah you know I got
them parse one tack it's the out of you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did we are laughs welcome to the iron
Lords podcast in the Lords of gaming
dotnet make sure you can hear me off is
the ojd game just make sure you give me
some time I hate when Tobias does this I
hate your jet so let me know I'll be
everybody let me know each and let me
know your hair soft so I'll talk to him
real quick when I put up it up no Xbox
ah but yo just make sure y'all can hear
what's long yeah yeah okay look someone
said no Xbox topic technically that's PS
now subscribers as an Xbox will make
sure the joint where the audio levels or
what a visually show even though I know
they work so it's just right so they say
a week ahead we go we go we go no doubt
so look I on the first one we get it to
show home I allured salute to the realm
we are now part of the three thousand
subscriber club that makes me want to
look under my bed before I go to bed
every white dude and every K man
could've done it without you guys
support has been tremendous and yo you
gotta stop want to do a special happy
board a shout out to my man Lord Michael
Matheny a came Lord Halifax at we born
day to him as his birthday us you notice
they had to
look man and of course welcome to the I
love podcast and the Lords of gaming
dotnet episode number 159 it's not the
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day and today
we've got Final Fantasy and April NPD
PlayStation now subscribers next-gen
reveal events and potential PlayStation
5 Silent Hill reboot to discuss so we
gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen a game in
there's a risen Lord to the realm here
at the round table
my co-host the cold most my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of reviews and the heart
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict that we do sir doing pretty
good I'm actually wider wait like I got
rules I haven't got rules in attic world
you can't call him but laid above me and
say I'm a redneck oh it's ok first off
what carne does never come out and call
me a redneck when we go here act like he
doesn't increase will you support it yes
your legend brother you allege it was
good over there what you can play I'm
playing I'm playing destiny all you back
at it bad try to get that season pass
all that done that's all I care about
I feel other than that everything's
finished expect I really I really don't
have anything to play at the moment
until minecraft dungeons comes out
Tuesday we gonna talk about that lies
huge things going on with my crap the
only thing I've really been doing is
watch kid smooth clay I just
so I shot the kids movement forgetting
it done I know there was a lot of you
getting that money
yeah Lulu to the bag I never hated man
get this man out I want to know when
they gonna learn to stop doubt in this
man once he plays sock you know yeah man
you're better than me is like I think if
anything kids who showered showed that
last of us on ground it ain't that hard
like I was saying literally just walk up
to people multiple a eyes in a row and
just beat them to death boy do me a
solid we actually missed a check from we
got sweaty submit for the $2 super chat
salutations lords in chat the book of X
Oh guys give it to little give it to him
like a bag you'll get that book of X
right quick
what's the neck and then we got the JT
game it with the $20 super tech super
tech works
Wow what what a one game for each
platform that you would like remade and
what genre would you like to see each
platform better at what was it basically
what one game for each platform that you
would like to be remade and what is not
would you like to see each platform
better at okay so let me let me hit this
one okay I want Xbox to remake jet force
Gemini oh I was Nintendo to remake Mario
RPG the real Mario a change not not this
not since they have now and I want
PlayStation I don't even know actually
to what I want place I got my mind I'm
thinking um Jack and Dexter I would like
like what like a Ratchet and Clank style
brought back from jak and daxter I'd
like Xbox to obviously increase that
story orientated games my station
increase the multiplayer only Ted and I
would say Nintendo were just fixes all
of that like say that I can't think of
stuff right now King you said you got
the one deck
yes my joint for Xbox is Blue Dragon one
I want that was so good for me man
I wanted Microsoft to be on that Peter
more joint with RPGs you know like Miss
Walker and stuff like that
PlayStation battle arena toshinden oh
yeah when I got hot position and I got
that better wrong yeah I solved that's
what I left you in the bushes
I don't know we say I betrayed Sega when
I saw that already did I'm over here let
me know everybody polygons ain't the
same yes some people in the chat every
one of the chat feel free to do that if
you guys want oh my god yo dudes first
of all a big about male is pay right we
got you caught up before that writes off
you're good you come yeah we have we
have two more oh no we got three Bob
again Lynch I'm gonna leave okay let me
guess I'm gonna kill you right now hallo
did it dawn is going yeah let me get Liz
yeah get that tada super chat so just
give me ten out of ten ten German I
should say correct not to interrupt
introductions but I got a salute the
Lord's on another fine Sunday drunken
fist fighting style FTW shall it can we
have a dick green screen a trucker
headed you know what you guys if we get
a hundred and fifty likes in here I will
wear a truck oh no you got a little il
peach I get no I will wear a truck hat
for a whole episode we get 150 likes on
this part oh yeah by the end of the show
I've heard it made my bro but ready to
put it out there so I'll get the next
one man drunken ninja with the TRO super
chat xbox has to revisit Jade Empire
classic snatch that away from by Obama
did not you're not doing anything with
it so maybe solo also chat from slow-mo
Bobo Xenogears for PlayStation and Jet
Set Radio future for Xbox
it's sad that you gotta bring back Jet
Set on on on xbox because they are Sega
me Xbox to me they need to do banjo
right I mean banjo right yeah I mean
give me a platformer that it's it is but
I don't think I'm good the so of the
[Music]
let's go this is not what I would
classify as a good yeah we hardest algae
family Oh a 100% it was good and you
know what it is I'm all about supporting
the passion this is this gave me my one
person out one person I want him to get
the bag so bad it's not gonna happens
when
really already working on parts so to
say don't PC sorry to interrupt you yes
far too about we are talking about shall
inverse routing continue continuously
that's my major Nelson because you know
why Major Nelson announced that cuz
Major Nelson was just like us me yeah I
don't even know some white glove man
swell you know he's so authentic
you don't never switch up yo he I know
he was down with their driving movie
this Saturday Xbox hunters reckoning
directly directly yes no place to go no
place nation had some actually just
mention that to me recently you want to
see Paris I even come back of that game
restore Haiti's with the $2 super chat a
ninja gaiden for Xbox of course and
where is twisted metal yeah your once
they did their jury in the bushes
bullying you think twisted metal can
have live in this kind of yes yes I mean
if you had if you if it was like a
technical tour de force you like the car
we are like would be interesting about
because I've never been a big like
twisted metal fan I played them like I
would play a battle royal twisted metal
yeah I would almost like a Destruction
Derby con you guys remember destruction
I remember Destruction Derby for the
PlayStation that's when I first saw
deforming polygons and detection like a
lot of first understand yeah you're
jumping it now on this wave thinking
this PlayStation for God it's not God it
makes me laugh but it makes me laugh
well you you know you have your haters
out there and you see people calling us
like you know what do they call this
after that one dude
always be put here you are I like that
do you do that one on Twitter until
people addict just said that if he gets
a hundred go let me let me finish what I
was playing then we talk these other
supernatural crazy yeah so I finally
finished the main story in Odyssey Oh
finally
so I finished Cassandra's like her
family story the brothers don't go into
it okay so you're pretty much their
addict so any if you have all the DLC it
kind of leads right into the DLC in
today I just I fought the brother on the
wars place in the army on that island
girl situation I'm sorry
at this point though King like if you
play if you didn't play Assassin's Creed
Cassandra did you really play Assassin's
Creed honestly I'm not afraid of my
sister's dug in you down like Sondra
you're not scared of Alexi oh because I
know he do the same exact thing
by the time I got to him I beat him
- oh no he's got - I got the AlphaTech
that I like I like to catch things on
fire so everything we talk about what I
do
finally finally got to that and I
downloaded haven't played it yet but I
need to get that on the saints row the
third the remastered but when I saw
breakdown wait a minute they really went
in because really when it was almost I
was tempted to get it for the switch
when it came on the god let me hold on a
second let's see what our liniment
seconds we got we gotta go we are so
much so funny right now we gotta go so
we finished first okay so next one is
dragon wolf with the two galas with
potential pound I need a new Riddick
escape from butcher Bay yes oh my god
mm-hmm pixel busy with the finalists of
the chat I cop part 1 & 2 on PC months
back and then cop the Xbox version ain't
the best fighter but respect for the
fields of kung-fu cinema 2 p.m. cinema
yes exactly 2 p.m. channel 5 cinema HR
to follow us which at Microsoft for Xbox
and nightmare creatures yo I actually
recently there was a nightmare creatures
reboot in in the works I don't know when
I got can but they were creatures is
it's like a third person like horrible
either for the original they I think
they had a part two for the original
Xbox and actually the n64 had a version
of it as well yes that mech assault no I
just want to say it is you might get you
wish
oh yes I've of exclusive key I'm sorry
being I've had multiple
you might get your wish because a
certain head of something is actually a
fan of that game so you might get your
wish
yeah and mecha salt is the one that's
more action-oriented because mega aureus
fantastic but it's not for everybody
right so it's a straight of action game
flow Delphis competent we got molds
cream with this we also which at I post
on Twitter for addict to get the 150
likes
we already almost had a hundred so I
guess I'm gonna be wearing a trucker hat
I'll put the water dose off with the
water through yeah will do that will get
that will get you every color I was it
was it was face
we got face no oh yeah yeah we face
wears very have to said you again so if
she's only put games day and day on PS
now yes that's exactly what my point was
gonna be would they have four games in
the top 20 MPD well you would need the
sony faithful to get over themselves
first and then and then buy in faithfuls
don't buy games oh I'm gonna keep it a
buck with y'all it's only faithful do
not y'all represent though they're like
1% babies Ellen 1% go shout out to IOP
spending this last of us money on your
pocket at agape I pick Dada seat up
again congrats on the idea WC lockness
shout out yes sir baby
thank you brother you're super proud I'm
gonna get into that we'll talk about
absolute kiddo I found out they're
moving sure for sure Congrats he's
making ever gotten mad they celebration
let his victory will I was crazy record
label and
he was always Billy Rock was here's how
you like me down Louie with the $2 hat
give me a new Altered Beast made by
ninja - yes nebula oh I want necessary
to make a dead space reboot yeah I say
we all know dumbest with the chats yeah
so the King was going on we gonna get to
the cake wait you fit it that was just
that you just did in theodicy man after
after uh I'm done hold on hold on
shout out he changed his name is his
birthday speech EJ's yeah - trucker hat
hollow $2 super Chet join the cause
addict is pretty nice over here you get
that - 150 by the end of the podcast it
takes a minute to guess fanboys don't
forget to take your joy Wow - the
reference I got that I'll be the first
to say say I wanna let you know he's
obsessed with that game come bloody Roy
a plasma sword yes
and your Bilstein you don't relaxed is
always fantastic she was all about the
fighting genre but I remember toe ball
oh yeah yeah yeah 60 frames per second
yes remember that course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this a.k.a the XS
gamer whoo the lord of combat sports the
returning king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement cool beloved
Lord King are we doing fine you dudes
know what it is with her yo y'all made
her go viral you made her do her thing I
really appreciate the comments shout out
to lemon one away dragon the right hand
is Zeus my brother from another mother
black brother you see the production
value my G you know I'm in step that
joint up yeah it's doable all better
I think the brief it's lighting the
production value the the way you the
presentations gotten better
oh thank you sir to someone that like
literally could like I I really rather
watch like opera or something than like
but than anything comic related but he
talks in the beginning the ones like you
know King doesn't have an issue talking
whatever right when you're recording
yourself a little bit you pause a little
bit I'm like I'm right now this is not
King wait wait a cut like 20 episodes in
you get his feet in and then you could
tell I can just throw it flow you put
bars is crazy
effortless though Oh out did the lipo
any chance cuz I see you in a minute
you know say we will make sure you're
good I'm glad to see you brother
that's
so gang okay okay whoa okay
this is what I've been playing me being
offline I've been that offline dude I've
been putting myself in sauces creed
Odyssey I've been putting in probably 10
12 hours a day all these wild little
missions and then okay shout-out to my
stupid behind when I found out then once
you reach a certain level you don't no
longer have to level up all this armor
you can have your favorite armor and
just change the skin resources to you
know how I was so broke just stealing
I'm just gonna steal it all I'm just
gonna get one of the people woods just
tearing up all the wood I was doing
everything just to get resources until I
found about that joint so I went I got
the whole Achilles armor
I was watching Troy yes Oh is there
anyone else I'm in this Assassin's Creed
Odyssey okay
that's now you like it I got it I got it
now I'm a fan of the old gods I'm a fan
of like you actually it is a good it's a
good game I'll just lander yeah that
would be a disrespectful go since you
see but I like I just heard yeah you did
you would deal it with teaming up and I
new deal I love that game so I have to
all my best slander but it's nice but
goes no no anyway that game is it's like
okay so I grew up watching Jason and
akka knots and stuff like that right so
this game within itself I thought
origins was the greatest Assassin's
Creed I must bend the knee oh right now
literally this game is the game if you
don't have it you're not a gamer
next Wayne for $60 and let's just say
you got the whole DLC pack let's see
let's say you put it or you can be like
me share there's a library kid and I pay
a day in the pocket watching we got to
get a mood join shout out to the mooch
if you did this and you pay like a
hundred or whatever cuz I got the whole
DLC yeah literally this game can last
you months wow you just doing everything
gold go to one town yeah and sit there
and just try to help everybody and do
everything in at one time to find all
the little secrets in one town it is
nuts and then I found out some other
stuff that's gonna happen man I gotta be
fighting these dead gods like Ajax and
Achilles and all and I'm doing the spear
move and I was doing this
yo I said this these do they mostly I
would love to just sit in a room in a
motion a perspective over how was going
down okay
Shaolin vs. wu-tang I just got goose
bones right now saying it bro and the
first match I took I got my butt
destroyed oh yes some joint well you
know that's more Eagle Claw the Eagle
net yeah yeah I'm gonna take master mo
got my blood smoked like a cigarette
right smoke and then I said you know
what let me be true to my essence I took
you call them Rama the golden God
yes yes I ended the game whoa I
proceeded to beat the breaks off of this
game now when you get to the board where
as candles be pitch for two frames per
second a slideshow I'm planning on my ex
I said man is that's when I pause and
look is any way I could put down the
resolution you
this dude hatch he didn't budget they I
know what happened up the dudes played
the game I know it's a little corny yeah
he had all the music yes voiceover
you'll be even got the jib can oil Oh yo
well it's ten frames and two frames per
second right and in the DB thwack is
that what you did just like if I became
with developer and you when you had this
stupid build the fight of a game kind of
like you know so Moe said is not to
frame per second or PC cathodic yes you
know yo the tree fall in the forest kiss
who named his PC Xbox so if I purchase
it on nine ain't no crossbar field I
gotta get his brain to answer come on
down oh you just wasted your brain when
I thought I was like oh this is a game
pass pass right now when I'm mad I get
past all they should addition I did not
put it on
maybe call to my budget I know Larry ran
in his office it was like yo my man to
put out the game let me see the day one
patch to cat car might just be the King
of Fighters might be thoughts and
Cheetara is slim dick oh yeah kiss
smooth for King find out a super chat
Lord King David I have he's laughed out
loud
oh he have three hundred thousand track
of me I didn't buy any armor I could
lend rock of me I won I can't talk about
you know fines but I could talk about
her isn't that drugging me is drek moon
you can tell I know it's just listen I
know he wanted me he tried to pitch it
he try to sell it shoutout to Larry
white gloves her it was like you're not
dragging my name down with that I will
say early access version of the second
one even an early access its hold to an
early access on Steam yes he's getting
his bread right now and throwing the
bread back into party I'm reaching out
to him to I'm a deaf we got it we got a
do so he Brooklyn sir
yeah no he was at the spots we was that
getting the flavor get here we got it we
don't work on that but yes so that's
what was going on been doing it got to
chitara going you got that going to did
that sizes create anything goes wrong
I'm gonna tell you this if y'all like
this statue here oh the statue that came
the same day I was doing that video whoa
this statue is coined this is this field
of magic I know
tingles your little cartoon face I know
it does there's no trials yeah yeah you
know you know you know but this one
character that's crazy
all right so we get mad that's that's
coming oh yes I'm doing it Monday well I
do all my videos Monday and and then I
do multiple edits and cuts and then I
just throw it in the garbage it's my own
words there might a house ensued a super
chat cube LEDs no good for next-gen no
not necessarily
it's just I will say this the old LEDs
are stepping it up in terms of the 120
Hertz and in terms of the age of the
HDMI to program compatibility and fright
wise yeah that's the C 9 is really
calling my put me on CT mark you can do
Mike Hewlett but that's I think now is
probably like it's 7000 but um you can
do my now to get you there what all it
yeah all right it's basically the same
thing just like the plasma school no I'm
saying is that the plasm was eventually
rectified it so that's why the cue plays
alright now that book is if you're
sitting there for 10 hours you put a
stagnant thing on your screen cover yeah
no doubt no doubt
so you already know and of course we
have the gaming ninja himself the
shinobi Lord kognito spread never
illness in the rumble ILP not tell me
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear yo vacation destiny has been
fantastic job I got like four games
finished I've been like it is I realize
how productive I am as a gamer
we intensity doesn't dominate my life I
did get my felt with to know so he
bought this you could leave me a little
shout to the last word the teasing teddy
we had on there man
we're down with fire team chatting all
the boys over there man you know had a
fantastic show it was super late please
this boy he gets so technical as far as
the aspects behind the game and what we
could predict it was going on so salute
to that still working on gears tactics
ma'am and absolutely love that got to
this crazy boss fight crazy chapter I'm
in love with that game as a lot of
twists there guys
with them submissions don't write attic
we agree them side missions got to go in
bushes because it's just too much
mandatory so I don't even want them in
the bushes man like is there something
below the bushes yeah take the side
missions against tactics I've gotta kill
the bushes up they got to go in the bush
because again it not side missions
they're mandatory minimal they will let
you advance the campaign like if I
wanted to just do the campaign I can't
write like there's three side missions
to pick from but you got to do two
before you can get to the next chapter
I'm like no it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be so just wrong it's just repetitive
it's destroyed three types of side
missions it would be so bad if the main
missions weren't the same mission
structures the side missions right I
will say this like I said production
value gameplay like the overwhelming
odds but the thing that's so dope is
that - that our execution mechanic
allows you to go again so if you get it
off it is a person that executes it's
your whole team the whole team gets to
eat so that's the counter to
overwhelming are they got every enemy
class they got it is such a homage to
two gears universe and the story is just
so far no wait oh my god yeah I can't
wait it's really really good so I'm
gonna do that and of course I had to
demonstrate the skill of shouting I said
I took all sneak at first at first leg
guys they don't they don't got no kick
in so I actually I know what I got they
got their damn that's fine but I wanna
pick one of these on and I knows races
but you do now what the white bean top
American American flag
that represent the downfall of channel 5
min just jumped out of the Mist that's
what best confusion about when it got
martyred and they got guns and cars
authenticity Babu I like myself
if you won't place a white guy you might
have to apologize engine respect to our
Asian counterparts respect I serve
people I don't like seeing a kung fool
killed
yo side boss I know this is a long issue
cyborg is the greatest red kick has ever
done in his life we was watching kung fu
flicks right so in our minds shot at the
shot everything taken late thought
everything they did at it was real
we were like these more than your nicest
kung fu' practitioners they do their own
stunts they are filled one day we
washing it in the crib so kid goes yo
pause that so it got to a point where we
pause and see the [ __ ] stunt double
and we realize that wasn't our man and
then it lifts the layer behind are we
like you're my man do his own stunts
look at the little Mexican what yo I I
took the curtain from the ranch when I
follow my man did it cuz I was watching
my man
big clothes I had put blood in everybody
snow you literally ruined those
seventies those flakes first that's
right
[Laughter]
I just got a cool hat it's a shot at the
King for destroying part two is on beta
I'm saying he's gonna come out and I'm
saying we definitely gotta support a man
he's doing it out here but yeah I'm
gonna support him also Brooklyn we had
to sort of a shout outs to I know
cilantro
salute to my brother Lord rage virus
Lords that gave it that they're out here
with the amazing minecraft dungeon the
secret article shout out to IG and shout
the windows central jazz court in charge
of Joseph not like these guys really
really gave us the kudos it usually
doesn't happen for a smaller entity like
us I mean we were still knew when to
come up and to get that recognition by
your peers so I gotta give a super
island off to the entire lords of gaming
down there team the editing staff
everybody man the text and the text says
tune with my old school the edit limiter
yeah hit the editorials yah when y'all
go to Lourdes a game in.net there's a
section right at the time says must read
these are some of our most personal
real-life stories by a lot of our
editors they are editorial I put my I
stand on my square for our editorial
team and they are fantastic man
everybody's doing it right now
everybody's killing so please check that
mush resection
please check out that minecraft does
raise I see you in there I'm super proud
of you guys man we couldn't have had a
better team the last thing I wanna shout
out to them and never forgot I got the
latest members a little bit so shout out
to uh David Yuri on you know say okay
I'm over salute to him and Excel you
know I'm saying you lash out the Lord
Jesse and of course our brother I
believe our Croatian brother Lord
challenged our challenge missile salute
to him make it super proud of you guys
lords gave that man we're moving out
here man you don't understand that that
made my day I don't know how y'all felt
what y'all sorry what
Wow yeah yes yeah it's it's amazing man
I can't even talk about anyway so that's
what I got on that but yeah as far as
the game you already know what that is
almost getting to this pole so last week
I'm sorry okay okay no all right we got
smoothy smooth for the final switch at
Lord Kenton could the next statute be
the Russian strongman from the X group
no matter what I'm two minutes you know
for fact who it is because you watched
all the way to the end you saw that
little nugget that I dropped down for
you committee smile I'm a hitch would ya
wanna something maybe with the two
dollars which at yo-yo you gotta listen
to what a glassed I was so Hank 18 the
dealer came up with little people talk
but shot listen BAE I was upset with
that the real kung-fu dudes in my movie
man my secret if I can imagine him
listening like what about lost
partnership I'm sorry I just we just we
had to talk you watch these movies time
and time again right go to had the veil
pulled back it's like it's like you know
it's like total walking behind the
curtain and seeing like those wrestling
fans that realize wrestling's fake yeah
listen this don't stop don't say that
don't let that one you don't wrestle him
you say I must say this I did it purely
out of my mom my Christmas was ruined
that's when I found out there was no
Santa Claus
yes and I had to ruin everybody else's
Christmas I literally knew what I was
doing I came there with an agenda and I
knew how to do it to them so I was
making sure that I destroyed everybody's
dreams like my dreams was destroyed I
did that for you salute the shaolin
wudang give you a lot of promotion
brother so you gotta we gotta get please
give me that game for free yeah
eighty last people results I hated the
people had spoken to the question with
the latest Unreal Engine 5 tech demo
reveal running on PS 5 hardware how
important is it to you engaging the
playstation 5 performance the winner of
our threeway il people at 45% was it's
just a multi-platform engine and not a
real game group coveted at second place
at 27% was I don't care into these
next-generation consoles do 60 frames
and raise it close at 2601 was 27 was 26
at last place was gave me the true
feeling of next-generation tech on the
PlayStation 5 group so shout out to all
the lords who participated Lord you are
victorious
so I mean beginnings I was victorious in
the stream last day how we feeling what
so what's the Lord's man Lord Cognito
King David sovereign addict addicts my
agent you know you guys I was actually
just about to tweet you know how I
annually do like my top favorite
youtubers and podcasts and whatnot umm
well here spoiler alerts and I lords
podcast as jump easily says number one
song to my favorite podcast it is crazy
because you guys I consider you guys
peers friends obviously we know each
other I could come in T fact if it
wasn't for this stupid virus and I think
see you guys right right so it's it's
weird but I really like this podcast how
come in this is the this is the only
podcast I put I I'm actively involved in
like fun chat is more than any other
podcast and whatnot and it's not me just
hyping you guys up for like ah maybe you
guys are growing let me jump on a
bandwagon it's just that I enjoyed you
guys I was like dude these guys have
like the charisma thank you the talent
and everything and it's going to blow
and I just can't I'm not thing is I get
to witness it from start to finish so it
is cool to see it come together and it's
very exciting it's very very exciting
and I just really want to just tell you
guys you guys like have a dope show I
love the podcast and it's like something
especially now we don't have like sports
and stuff like that so it's like it's
Sunday it's like all right let you ask
my wife I was like we got her to get
home because like so we got here at like
1249 helped her with the groceries
Indian Rick turned on my phone so I can
hear on loudspeaker is it helped her out
and they've ran to my computer to listen
now so I just want to say congrats you
guys deserve everything and David whoa
King David well you you're spitting some
game that was you know when we was at
Boston yeah yeah it was two years two
years what yeah you go fast right yeah
you were spitting some game and I was
sitting I was listening I thought about
it cuz I went home early when that train
the bus ride cuz I didn't take a train I
took a bus I was like it's like you know
Lane kognito like the focus in his eyes
when you were working on a kid laptop
and I'm like yeah my too and I'm like
the way they and I was thinking about
like the moments of the microphone and
dude like hey you know there's something
about I was like these cats are legit
appreciate and I'm like I like these
better I really just don't like that's
why I'm just always I'm always tweeting
and attic this is give you guys a heads
up Anna hits me up every K do I want to
UM do you want in on a podcast I'm like
nice when they enjoy the show it's like
I'd rather watch then because I like the
flow of everything I was like just you
can ask them sometimes I just like not I
should show you guys like I'm interested
in what's going on us and I just sit
there and watch the next thing I know
after the podcast a quarter of my day is
gone let me play some games now go and
do what this shoutout to guys I love
your stuff trust me when I'm telling you
now I'm not just saying it cuz you
saying it but remember when you was like
I don't know man it's like I noticed a
bit during our conversation I was having
I was like nah FTW man just do that do
that do that right if you if let's just
say you just you to select or whatever I
wouldn't got the funniest video do you
in sake don't yeah oh yeah it's saved in
my favorite I only got probably like two
videos and tool I mean three videos and
two of them is mine
right but that joint with you I usually
watch it probably once a month - damn
that was I was so happy so look man this
real quick kick first a little brother
because again it's always been genuine
with you and we always respect you know
I'm saying our peers like you say and
this week is like we just we could just
really connect like we're literally
right next to each other it's crazy but
salute you because you are definitely
and like Kings say doc cuz you're here
one of the most entertaining streamers
let's just put it out there like there's
no one more if you want entertainment
especially with difficult games is
nobody better so like with this drink we
know what it was concentrated all that
but you've got another one dying your
bail under your belt complete it you
don't say so what you want to scale your
let's go shield victory loud yeah and I
know well for starters I'm betting that
like 33% but know what I feel really
good like I said you know obviously
there's some controversy controversy you
know the money and everything but dude I
felt
good because certain people got to watch
me win Wow
I just said all I really want to do is
get this done so this person can watch
me win in all his fans have to watch so
it feels good I'm wearing my PlayStation
hat today Oh what yo you so busy you
gonna be honored as because I know
there's some PlayStation Lloyd says that
didn't even touch that game one grounded
um you're some of my peers that you know
took advantage of the game on normal and
survivor I need to are grounded so I'm
looking at my charted yes today you know
just to remind people that the best spot
you know the one that's putting on these
shows for these PlayStation games I want
to say on a serious note great feel like
I said I have a had a little extra money
to splurge around authorities it goes
everything so but the money thing was
even nobody could have given me anything
I think I still would have been fine I'm
honestly it's all for the fun I don't do
these challenges all the time I don't
know yeah I don't I don't ask for these
things yeah come to us run away from
them
yeah I run away from the later and when
I do it I do it but the thing is what I
want people to understand is is that
yeah sure we do it in this time it was
needed given what we're doing going
through there's no other areas you know
we are just finished a Michael Jordan
documentary for all you people I love
that documentary
your man is a fraud you want to tell the
real story oh yeah I'm not gonna ever
watch that show
scary fatigue kick kick bit Messier
penny continued kick no the biggest
thing is that when I do these challenges
right I'm not the only one that comes
out with anything win or lose a lot of
people
yes other content creators come out of
nowhere people Twitter pages a blow up
and it gives everybody something to do
I'm in this time kid was on reddit Wow
PC gamer the the PC website not PC gamer
I think it might have a PC gamer when he
did the Scheck road think he's on their
website
what Moore's house got me the second row
code Wow but um no but a lot of people
benefit off of it and that's why I like
sometimes it the unnecessary hate that
it gets and people take it to tell you
too seriously it's like remember guys I
didn't want to do this to begin with but
on the bright side just look at you know
all the other people that was able to
like you come off with some people rely
on knowing bad news or next gen stuff to
get clicks and views and stuff like that
and Here I am right now if I wanted to I
can be that big a hole and count and
copyright strike several people's
channel
mm-hmm I mean but um I I guess people I
guess there's a lot of people
[Laughter]
appreciating like you know what came of
it and and everything you guys know you
guys you know you got bare-witness you
was there live with one of absolutely
every year this happens controvert
there's always gonna be controversy if I
it always goes like this right and let
me tell you guys a little bit of secret
talk to me right when I do these
challenges right especially if there's a
game I want to play um and I have to do
on the hardest difficulty this is gonna
be the preset for every other challenge
I do in the future chose the first three
or four streams I'm probably going to be
horrible that's where that's where the
funniest part is gonna come because
let's meet your acquaintance that's me
again I'm not used to things right
oh that by now it happened with
blood-borne first four scenes I was
horrible light and that's we're raising
the anger genre but that's a salute to
your controllers salute to you
turning point I'm going to get better
and when that happens that's when the
stream I I guess I become less funny
because now I'm more focused and I'm
going on and it happened every stream by
extreme v stream six I'm more planning
now I mean I'm in smooth gaming mode I'm
not go try to entertain you I'm trying
to game and if I get through I get
through if I don't I don't what Oh so
the fact that every year regardless
there's always gonna be like oh you
cheated you look that up and um
especially in what especially it started
with the Uncharted game where the thing
about Naughty Dog and their story based
Riven game is they want to do cutscenes
and theatrics they want you to be
emotional
so aims like that I was like alright if
I can't get through this encounter
I need a rush a checkpoint - yeah I was
just about to say I was like you have
bastard the speed pass things that you
don't need to be standing there do it
cuz the Naughty Dog games had that
monster closet thing where if you stay
back
yo just keep coming but it's all those
boys yeah yeah listen you've never seen
look up monster closet Uncharted -
mm-hmm there's a part where you're being
attacked by a helicopter right and it's
near the end of the game and they just
if you don't move forward yeah and you
stay behind cover they will just keep
coming Wow yeah also when I figured out
in my stream Mulla and the thing is I
don't know why people weren't wasn't
picking this up it came down to me
counting NPC's back and I was like okay
here's I like there's six NPCs there's
one per room this person goes this far
Wow shout out to you exposing their bad
programs often that last part I'm like
okay alright this guy's not gonna come
this far I can run back get em oh and I
know they're not gonna chase me I was
sure before I get their attention
and you think that average game they're
gonna run towards you right if you run
but they don't they go to a certain
point stop and turn around so about what
- a rule I can activate their sequence
without them seeing me the game is
program I if you walk here this carry a
good sign
counting cards any with their money back
kill somebody and there's a dude next to
him and he can run back to the beginning
of the room and that all had never
happened honestly there was the bends
where I started taking advantage of that
and then it was a part where on your le
and you got somebody is always best
obviously I played best when I had an
MPC with me like a hand because they act
as a distraction and what I learned late
was that okay every time cuz you know
you can't kill a clicker right oh one
hit yes however if they're tackling your
NPC you can't
oh okay no what about anti bait it's so
good that's how I was figuring a lot of
stuff out in his game and there's what
the thing that people don't understand
about this stream while my other streams
you know were lasted about 19 20 streams
right and with the Last of Us and it's
what people won't tell you there are
only two parts mm-hmm where I got stuck
and I stopped the stream hmm the other
like there's like is stream six what
about that what he had you upside down
with the guns broken controller in that
same stream though all the stuff like
our but I didn't stop the screaming I
like I got through that whole part
unless it was just one screen and the
thing is people don't understand it's
like dude I got every time I did a
stream I was getting through chunks of
the game so if you guys are thinking I
use like a guide you're actually calling
me a genius cuz you're thinking I can
record all this information and then
remember it and do it to perfection
you're better than a genius you said
that and broke the program not exactly
what they were doing and how the system
is I love the fact that you know down
like that now now they're upset now you
really
you really agree people agree - chatter
say never don't say they said that you
got to keep moving the Naughty Dog a
shout yawns yeah they said it's a lot of
it yeah yeah that's hopefully they
change that I was like I couldn't get
like tips from outside or go looking for
obviously guys and stuff like that which
is alright however um that didn't limit
me from using tips inside the game right
and it didn't limit me from using my own
streams right I would go back and write
because there were times I had good runs
and I died at the end and I miss it or I
got caught I got screwed on the
checkpoint yes sir go back every light
on the people that made timestamps did
and I'm like okay this was the run where
I got it okay how can I do that one
better I'll fill it in snow and then but
people and then also remember when I was
on my whole charade about the Last of Us
- and people want to discredit my
opinion right no they said you didn't
play The Last of Us when I was like yeah
I did I played it in 2015 they check my
trophies see they didn't want to admit
that Naughty Dog doesn't give you
trophies for beating or for playing a
game so my name I Pro fees I got one
back in 2015 and that was for crafting
right you wouldn't know the next time I
got a trophy in that game one we're not
beat it I'm not for fun easy normal
survivor and grounded shouts OH
so when they looked at and I was like
you I've been trying to tell you guys I
played this game in 2015 mm-hmm I played
it in 2015 but nobody wanted to believe
me could they wanted to shut me down so
I don't speak about the Last of Us - I
got you but we got recalled they spoil
it was a little spooky I'm gonna fit
here to show up no no we did to get your
victory lap get your last balls officer
yeah so I played the game and I try to
tell people and people were upset
because people at like Oaks I didn't
remember every sequence in order then
lying you you ever watch a movie back
from my 80s and the 90s mmm do you
remember parts but you don't remember
the order of the order of events
yeah do you watch it again play oh yeah
that's how this happens that
because the when I was telling people I
played last I was like dude I remember
being in some town against no I think I
would build something that was wit I
remembered that last part I remember
personally but like I don't know how far
wasn't a game because I wasn't tracking
I was when I wasn't doing it on there
any time yeah I get that ugly that's the
part I remembered is like are you all
July so when I was telling people oh
it's all coming back to me I do remember
that like doing this little brother yeah
remember meeting up with this dude in
the dam and all this other stuff now
it's just the more the stuff that was
more potent to me I stood out does it
resonate it yeah yeah I struggle that on
normal absolutely that's why I remember
that part so yeah right I'm sorry
well let's go and get these super chests
just a lot weird stitch ok stitch with
the $4.99 super jet so when you guys
make it big don't forget the little
people like me first of all never never
bro we ain't like never I left it on
this one purposely because mm-hmm that's
real never shot the cat daddy with the
two I switch at kid is the only person I
could watch foolish Reaves oh yeah girl
roni with the 10 dollar super chat after
showing his friends to mid second King
David shall forever be known as the
dream Krusty Martinez with the note
gaming Forte whoa
I'm their Forte with the Jack
saying oblate editing a video watching
smooth rage is the best entertainment on
YouTube but lets you serve this market
is yours yeah and thanks for embracing
salut that's a fact though everybody
else at the fourth day Oh MOC Martinez
dude a super chat kid with big fats out
real gamers for real game
did he beat you over at PAX no [ __ ]
beat me at e3 right yeah no no listen
what do you beat them both then cuz I
remember you guys played at PAX oh yeah
we play that packs inside the air BnB
right but that was sort of a rematch
we've been chasing each other for for a
year because nobody knows the history
between me and kit this is why I was
pissed off with kid this is how we had
the conversation now it's a whole big
thing behind that and but my brother was
in trouble now shout out to cog for
presenting it to me mm-hmm cut yellow
y'all don't understand how integral cog
is to everything he is the most even
killed most logical person that I've
known in my whole life he is he
literally takes the emotion out of the
situation and looks at it on both sides
and presented it to you as a man but you
may not like it he when he says that
joint in the beginning it may not like
it but he's going to give it to you in a
manner that you know and when he did and
I was like now my brothers in trouble I
don't care what anything that has to do
I will have a conversation with my
brother later so we had a conversation
with him well I had a conversation with
him and that's when we got to that part
we played the game now the first time I
played him who's that I did not know
what the hell I was doing and I Buster's
but we was fresh-faced okay legitly
fresh-faced at EA EA a little booth and
that's that hot Sunday we all turn extra
black I beat him man and he wanted the
rematch yeah so it was something I was
going wrong with that and then we
finally got a chance to get to the
rematch and then when we got to the
rematch he bust my butt so but then
that's how the whole thing for me
listen he's legit he's Latino I can tell
we know about kid he's a game he's a
real duel we may not always agree on a
piggys subtypes runs gamerpaige but as
far as a game as far as being a real
dude like again it's few people two
things people can say about their name
kiss boys one oh so I want to give you
[Laughter]
[Music]
that Final Fantasy 7 go rebake just drop
MPD's have dropped as some news came out
fellas
so news came out for you know the piece
of the game and you know I hope matches
in the chat let's be in their heads
dizzy
j-mo Porsche power I need these for this
because I told y'all I told y'all the
goat was I told y'all what was gonna
happen and the news came out the best
selling game of April 2020 instantly
becoming the number three best selling
game of the year and currently the best
selling game of the year on PlayStation
4 and then basically it's exceeded the
franchise histories for our sales of
Final Fantasy 15 which launched in
December 2016
so it salutis quick links or not I would
I got to get my boss off had to give a
boss off but I want to talk about MPD
now we got the funny part out let's talk
about him because it was an interesting
MPD and I'm saying we got the top 10
obviously
switch game coming in hot sauce we don't
even
this is how I know Oh mostly Martinez we
got stitch with the to protect hell no
thing is kid Belichick you know
from trucker hat welcome back welcome
brother added to the club jacket hat
let's go
but yeah mister look interesting MPD
obviously you know I'm saying we got the
top 20 game that's just but all that but
um yeah man we got the the top 20 games
man was really really impressed by was
he Final Fantasy 7 Call of Duty remake
animal Crossing's at number three then
we had on every 2k Grand Theft Auto Man
Jesus in at number five resident evil 3
call of duty at 7 mile or fair to
remaster that MLB the show still looked
at I'll be it well they dropped from 3
but they had the number 8 Matt is still
going strong it went up from um what you
call it some 16 and this oh oh oh I get
you I get sales these are sales yeah but
okay I'm these are saying those
downloads in there you don't think game
pass increases sales is a factual fact
increase sales while it's on game pad oh
alright
well at this point in time was dead just
because you know hating about it on the
podcast that I wasn't on I listen to
rights only in under that about how to
go is on game pads and then when I come
back let me give you a collision I was
being facetious when I was now came the
game past but MPD's show you that the
game isn't dead and maybe any pass gave
it new life maybe people touch the game
and game press and said you know what
this is worth my bucks
[Music]
look all due respect I just don't see
that I mean
ride a horse around all day all day pass
like you know what it's for free right
now you know what I want to you all want
to buy this no listen I'm gonna give you
the shout out to mr. so fancy ooh fancy
said that she had the game on
PlayStation right he was gonna give it a
try because it was on a game pass mm
yeah game pass you just had a person
that have your game already on a
competing platform from scratch it's in
game pad we do notice the X version is
you know the best I don't know she has
an accent not but I'm just saying like
did this is this is how the game past
effects happen is the is the hummingbird
effect it's over there let me try it now
what you try it let me buy it because if
it leaves remember you get the the money
or get a check out on the way out the
hummingbird effect works in a sense that
you try it you might say yeah I don't
want this game to leave let me let me
cop this right okay so we now it's a
face with 23 with the with the $5 super
chata he's like a counter to that the
game has increased Ori to sales that it
I think it's different for first party
stuff I do think what's what's the point
of buying a first party if you are oh no
it's never leaving game past that's if
you never leave and watch it and never
leave but when we get to what game past
numbers is in a minute you're gonna see
what it did I'm gonna tell you what it
did to Ori in a second but I'm just
gonna be bad to you let me get these
bars off real quick about MPD just some
things I noticed and I wanted to bring
it to your attention real quick um so
obviously we got the top tens from the
three paths I'm not gonna read through
each other
that'll be put too long but on April 4
arm switch got out very surprised
I shot I see an animal crossing but the
digital cells look like they're being
counted now and um yeah man so shout to
them because we gotta order
about david urea and i believe in super
dating those guys it actually sold
digitally more than Final Fantasy 7 as
far as four by the Senate for the month
and all that social ooh to the digital
sales on that and then Mary your card
song is going America always does that I
don't I wouldn't be surprised if we get
a full on America at nine yes so so to
them
now here's it a Playstation obviously we
know the Final Fantasy and then most of
the usual suspects as far as the
third-party shot the end will be the
show still going strong I did know this
all bro minecraft PlayStation 4 edition
oh yes oh crap D top 10 a Microsoft
cable plate what's this about
yeah and that means my crap it's just
minecraft and i'm sure with dungeons
coming you people get the minecraft
feels don't play minecraft we're trying
to load dungeons forever
no dear minecraft has been doing a whole
lot of virtual graduation so a lot of
people have been buying it or that right
participate really interested to see
microsoft game over there at the top 10
on PlayStation I thought that was
interested now here's the thing we got
to talk about it cuz you know the law is
gonna keep it fair you know I'm saying
so I'm looking at that that Xbox you
know saying top 10 and I'm like all
right call it Duty makes sense alright
call of duty tool makes sense grant def
okay 2k rest then I'm like why is
everything third party in the top this
the micro screen first party in the top
10 on it is there here is there any like
must to buy really that Microsoft the
post couple years there really is it
like there's really good games that you
know if you have game pads you can draw
like glory you know I think gif 5 is the
last like you know if you have an X you
gotta buy it like me and you've even
have to buy that because of gamepad so
we just said it like if you're it would
totally derail what they're doing with
game passes they were ever to remove any
of those first party games from game
passed like you know once you have it in
game pass you do have it for life it's
not worry about losing it so yeah
I don't expect by I just don't pass and
finish the game you could find on game
passed for $1 the months you know what
financially and you'd be dumb going and
buying it one game pass success well
yeah but that's just you just being
ignorant and stubborn you're just really
being stubborn when you have the money
in hand if you have $60 then you have
enough ticket to go buy a game pass for
a couple of months and get that game
anymore
so when they start counting getting past
engagement numbers then you're gonna see
a change in what MPD's and leaderboard
stuff like that look like the reason why
we're still stuck on this old way of
thinking and they're coming around like
you said digital sales is being counted
when they start to get into engagement
numbers microsoft has always been ahead
of the curve right right so they always
have been dictating you know how the
pace should be going and when they said
okay we're not gonna give you numbers no
more because that's a old way of
thinking and we're moving into the new
way of thinking a new way of thinking is
engagement because what they want you to
do is give residual dollar once I start
doing engagement numbers on games that's
actually out there then you're gonna
start to see what games are being
purchased and what games are being
played right they don't want that you
know cuz a lot of times you get games
and you just leave it on yourself I got
a lot of games in plastic that pisses me
off because I became a collector and not
a gamer right but if you start to look
at it then you start to see the
engagement numbers we keep talking about
Odyssey and I'm putting tons and tons of
hours I'm not the only one doing this
and this game has came out a long time
ago I put 20 hours and Lost Odyssey in
the past week and I listened I said can
you you may be on to something and maybe
it's just me with the old way of
thinking you know I'm saying but it was
just so I'll be on it was surprising not
to see one Marcus off first but this
year just for this month I mean if you
think about it what's really really mad
now people are like maybe if you look at
the gears 5 that month that came out I'm
sure it's on there you know
it's something I just want to monitor
going forward when Microsoft then drops
a first-party exclusive I want to sit
not gonna go in there unless unless you
see a simultaneous release on Steam or
something like that I don't know that
you're gonna see that it's not going to
be I know it was the number uh gear
stacked it was the number one thing sold
on on Steam for like it was like a week
straight it was it was the first thing
yes even it did it don't like you know
the argument that oh I don't want
another launcher on my computer whatever
what's the money really things really
get down to the to the metal and you
took my money yeah you ain't gonna care
about any extra launcher on there on the
computer fair enough fair enough
and last question I got for y'all what
the MPD stuff is obviously obviously 597
number three already for the year so my
question new y'all right is what do we
think you know say as far as like what's
one of your picks you know for who gonna
win this year as the overall
best-selling game for 2020 collar dude I
think John wick has enough pork watching
me know yesterday catching goosebumps my
guy like you don't understand I really
feel that he's a transcendent dude his
name ring bells like they they attaching
him to the Silver Surfer to Ghost Rider
on this listen you got your knees so you
bout to be a whole truck outfit
so overall second let's go right now
Oh point in point by the end of the year
who sells more Call of Duty or cyberpunk
that's the only thing we need to do oh
is it going down well and you say Call
of Duty comes out and let's say October
November
oh no because we already got cyberpunk
if it comes the game pass then I'm
already loose the game's afoot all right
what I believe in cyberpunk so much
because I really believe and I know they
call it Duty dudes is nuts I got some
nuts on my on my timeline did they don't
stop playing it but I don't know I mean
going into the next I don't know things
I don't know maybe people might want to
be something different this is my hope I
know I know
Call of Duty's that go yeah I know it is
and I know Call of Duty comes out and
wins every Punk is a true RPG and a lot
of people are scared of one stupid once
you open up the menu when you look at
let me ask you guys a quick question
that did Witcher 3 beat Call of Duty I'm
going go you're rotting down look right
now let's get the chatter involved Lord
King has been limited it won't for me
losing or two for King back they say I'm
telling you
John wick effect is crazy
do you know I believe in him I'm like
he's the one guy on but I'm something
and I think you breakfast lunch and
dinner you say now I'm gonna turn into
Hannibal Lecter and ponies arguing again
saving money I'm not right before you
then we got cause a game about choice
shots wheelchair I have bought more
games because of game pass all my
brother required yo $10 yeah
I gotta get a Lord switch cake over
there you know what we've been doin
Tobruk way no you know is this abuse at
this point child abuse you know they
salute the reclaim your in there and
then I think we are caught up there
right we all no no no no we gotta face
again we're gonna wear let me do face if
kingship thinks only four whooping
Xboxes jack xbox now is better for it
who did that for you Sony did oh [ __ ] I
am very appreciative for them to get
humbled mmm you should be too but you
win when you don't understand what is
happening for us because of somebody
getting a butt beat you know I mean
literally if they were just Shaq jealous
this generation if you would have been
shacked if you just bring a Rock's all
over the place getting mess up if the
dawn didn't mess up your PlayStation is
gone you don't even get daughter Wars I
think we got a he said get them knees
ready all this
we missing we got linchpin with the $5
to protect with the 5 was a german real
talk watching you guys is just a pure
joy the amount of camaraderie
brotherhood and love between you is so
felt it is blissful and contagious
except for when I take his knees bring
the beef some hot sauce on that barbecue
sauce and we pull up with the place you
know your knees we're gonna we're gonna
have to get some into the bushes in that
chat for our Lord King and his knees
it's Call of Duty you've never seen
history happened you know what it is
i'ma let you I'm gonna give you some
little inside knowledge in God cognos
this when I'm on to some time on it he
was watching watching hyperbole yes and
Eli Manning had the ball it was more
time on the clock and I said I think
it's like 12 seconds over this is the
legend of a baby
no one stands on there Square to the
very end more than King I will give this
man can see the light in the end of the
tunnel in pure darkness yeah Jordan has
two four five and your man is gonna get
smoked penny is Shaq
don't be one of those people that it's
like those minigames that you have in
those party games where you have to go
to the certain section that's not gonna
fall keep staying in there he knows it's
gonna fall but he's gonna follow that's
gonna be at the post office meal and you
act like you beat me and you don't we've
won 4-1 right now right technically
Texas I got one of your knees too but we
didn't know oh my god we got a lot of
stories with the 2000 tech what if
cyberpunk 27 is 77 is in game pass who
did that Oh start the provocated rabbit
tartar rally with King on believe we got
that we have fastback gold G and og
podcast lord king pj arm show said nice
game cod and the Pats go woke up yes
careful eat those knees to carry those
boxes right now I'm telling you just had
to carry on speaking yeah what happens
if if cyberpunk goes in game pass you
lose the bend the knee to em across the
an you lose the boom the next column
when I win both his knees I will figure
out how to split his body like I'll give
you like you know that the ankle down or
something I'm a nice platter we can do
like you like bubblegum he's already
about we already know that I would be
the one online talk about the time you
already told you all your games in that
back capacity your mom already shook
your knees to display hip-hop I believe
your wheelchair so you can real quick
Gaga shout this rule kick your kick is
that loud at the USPS with a box of
these I feel like the FBI would come in
on that these topics papa bear for these
show guy Lord cane without child
protective ease but we got some stuff to
talk about man oh look
oh we got some PlayStation now new now
this is the rest of the show we
understand what's going on man you want
me to set this thing up which was going
on so it looks like all our PlayStation
now you know I'm saying obviously the
numbers have come out looks like Oh 202
million people in Santa stole millions
up for the 2.2 minutes and now using
PlayStation now now in comparison
despite their success which has come out
is that Microsoft's game past is over 10
million or you described which estimates
and puts an Xbox one console sales about
and that's half of the ps4 so with half
of the console sales they still have
more of the active users so pretty much
they were just saying how long
basically the article shot to Business
Insider they actually had a very spicy
article take Microsoft's Xbox is already
crushing Sony's PlayStation when it
comes to creating the Netflix of gaming
and it has huge implications for next
generation consoles so King you were the
first to bring this across our time line
in the news broke so yeah let you get
your balls off man the millions on
versus you know obviously the
PlayStation now servers and the gamepad
service the way you feel about this sir
Carbon deed though [ __ ]
- yeah listen you know I did struggle up
your did you yo can your Trudeau agree
to get PlayStation participation trophy
at least definitely probably are in the
rear I mean I'm like they even think
Nintendo subscription service whatever
the heck they got it's probably being
they don't got anything I think they but
I mean 2.2 million look at you guys my
god I can literally see him patting them
on the head look at you shooting at the
hoop this is what happens I mean they
have 700,000 before I mean that was his
MO Oh
shout-out to jammed gym dance moves Ryan
getting um the old regime out and you
know teaching these dudes how it should
be done following the foot so filled
ominous maximus spencer and it shows
once you start putting first party
titles inside your service
once you slash prices once you bend and
mean to the superior service and
understand how it should be done
boys should be done I'm talking like
this style is identical to none care but
when you see you know the master chess
player of course you got a copy these
moves like why wouldn't you just you
what y'all really should be is mad at
yourself the one you don't own
PlayStation now and you own a
Playstation where you should beat
yourself that's that's one too you don't
support PlayStation now or maybe you
just started supporting PlayStation now
because they dropped the price and you
as fugu with your dolls maybe they
should have put it for three months in
you for a dollar maybe then you would
have jumped in to to the support maybe
you can get it up to ten right so shady
said okay and I say this
put those games date and day I will
purchase your service I will stick
around and I will never leave I fit
right but what you have to do is stop
treating me like like I'm dumb you got
to stop treating me like my money don't
matter and when they lowered the price
and they put spider-man and they put God
of War in it and then it removed it out
I think that I think they probably did I
think a date that day High Point is when
they have those games in there and I
think once those games left I think also
the people left - they probably was that
like three million and probably lost the
million subscribers once they took those
games out put those games in there give
these dudes what they deserve and stop
acting like you - keepers of the key
you're not losing anything my selling
your games and putting it in your
service actually giving them value give
it at it um do you think what do we know
the length of time as far as win
obviously don't kind of know a game past
I win the PlayStation now store I did
how much of a head start was my
questioning was they had about twenty
they started 2014 so went out 2014 as
far as a subscription service and so
it's a six year head start and because
we say game I'm sorry now it's six years
it's 6 years total that it's a total so
and then game pass would say he launched
on us I'm gonna say what 2016 16 17 yeah
I'm gonna chat if not no the year of
wind game pass I don't have that off top
I'm very curious out of kid noses well
either
yeah the Microsoft game pairs come out
yeah we I just want to know that year
difference as far as when PlayStation
now actually started versus game pass
because I want to get that in
perspective first or 2017 2016 is when
game pass started right and then you
said 2014 is Wow and to have that wow
that that's pretty impressive your head
start present so let's get let's get out
of it I'll get you back so much attic
real quick man so you know the numbers
can I know you don't really do the
numbers thing too much but like what do
you feel it about the you know the
places you're now numbers you know what
I'm glad you're asked
let's just be real here
you know the game pastures a better
value and it's apparent its facts the
consumers are backing this facts up
mm-hmm
PlayStation had the service two years
and in two years
Microsoft already started to you know
pick up momentum so if you put like the
two years what 2019 mm-hmm that's the
the same equivalent time that Sony did
Sony just now hit two million and
Microsoft probably hit two million two
years ago you know what do you say to
the people doubt that we're gonna play
fair what do you say to the people who
say look yeah giving that joint for a
dollar
I'm saying like that's why that's what
it is like I don't see people
complaining that Netflix gives the first
free month away for free so you know
it's that's how subscription services at
work you know they get you into the
servers for a low amount then they hook
you and they know you ain't leavin sure
is some people gonna leave the service
after they play the game yes the hard
course I've literally seen Kofi refund a
dollar on Microsoft before boom people
like him they're gonna do that people
like keV they're gonna do that they're
gonna you know get that first 30 days
I'm gonna play the guy that I want to
play then go move on that is not the
demographic they're targeting with this
service they're sorry they're targeting
people that you know don't necessarily
have the time to cost the going.i they
don't have the money to constantly be
buying this game so they're like fur fur
what a hundred and twenty dollars a year
you don't have to buy your kid you not
to play
Tommy anything Tommy got everything he
needs a shout out to you be a healthy
drinking no more soda into drinkable
prowl salute to you just get that propel
I would like to say this I would like to
say I support Alec and I've been as a
positive influence and him drinking a
loose salute to adding finally throw a
soda straight in the bushes and kiss
move still up in half got bad kid
what do you feel like with this whole
PlayStation now you know what the
numbers coming out now Xbox is killing
PlayStation in one category every time
you know it's crazy first when the
narrative was you know Xbox game pass is
killing Xbox is danger selling no games
is only more
fodder and all this stuff once some
positivity start coming out and devs
started talking about it and Xbox
started talking a little bit about the
engagement right then the PlayStation
side of things started talking about
well Playstation down got more games
Frank PlayStation now always now it's
knowledge it's now a better sort of oh
we got control before you guys now
there's like hype behind it but before
it was the server's they were disgracing
mm-hmm I think is what it showed Sony
and I'm pretty sure King David had
hinted at this and this book if game
pass one of my favorite things I used to
hear from PlayStation guys is oh
somebody in first place isn't gonna
follow the footsteps of somebody in
third place so what happens once Sony's
sees Microsoft they're obviously still
making money still making billions of
dollars in their gaming division why
right
why do you not selling as many consoles
as you guys but they're still selling
games they still get subscriptions
mm-hmm
so that well could this actually work we
saw EA attempt this and then they
expanded it to PC and then Microsoft did
it obviously and people point that a
better way because well you're getting
full access it's not just trials and
stuff like and then downloads downloads
yeah and you buy the games at a discount
if you want to keep them so they're
looking back they're peeping game
developers and publishers are hyped
about it
Sony watching Bethesda putting their
whole library catcon library and they're
like wait a minute
hold on there's clearly money you can
make in this subscribe because all you
have to say is the most money hungry
company out there and when they put that
on console they they expanded the PC
companies multi-billion dollar companies
do not expand to another demographic
unless the first ones making great money
we had to double down on what our kid is
saying didn't Herman house once he took
over he kind of alluded to subscription
services and that being a focus you know
say as far as services which is kinda in
parallel to
phil has always been talking about and
we had a sheet of private product prior
to that was kind of saying that the new
metric is engagement in whatever
whatever so it they duck that we are
seeing some shifts to some of the stuff
Microsoft has already been doing but
continue kit
yeah and in home herman hall so when he
when he came in he started talking about
PC to put out there subscription service
they come they went behind any 110
percent with you know obviously pushing
the console and the PC and they already
got a secret weapon caught it X cloud
which is gonna double their numbers in a
matter of six months one five I'm ready
thing about horizons Marie right now so
they had so they kind of went full
beyond it early and they started started
putting these included in their
marketing bills the you know be around
game path was all right not only that
we're gonna get this being game passed
at this time after a release or at de
Indias and so impression they got on it
late it's like they did a knee-jerk
reaction alright let's drop the price
all right I relationship with remedy now
let's put control in here put this in
arrow let's give like a time to uh limit
for our major first party exclusive to
be an area just won't be Dane date and
so in that did that when they dropped
the price they got the downloads in
there it's not coming getting there
their numbers increase but kid kid I
don't think it was a knee-jerk reaction
I think it was they really they got rid
of someone who was resistant and it's a
later later with that and in the same
day that he disappeared off the face of
this planet the price drops game keys in
there and the sales go up first party
games with a week right after the
weekdays no let me say this the guy that
I was touting up there so much was not
playing ball properly and he's holding
you back shout out to Jim dance moves
right for getting those numbers up and
and everybody keep telling you Jim dance
moves Ryan is a numbers guy
well obviously that must be true because
he got those numbers up in a short
amount of time he hasn't been in office
for two but not too long right he's he's
just got in there and he's looking like
little Phil shout-out to little feel
quick stitch you got 69 mm chat well
well well very messy stitch I see what
you doing there gay so we got after that
wait a minute I got a $5 super chair
from war born yeah sorry renting
Microsoft Azure services is like uh is
like when easy easy easy
when Dre day is my gate pass helps me
afford to super check we appreciate that
fastback and LG brother in a row then we
got wet exchange with super chat by Pony
logic all games and PS later games are
rubbish because you haven't bought the
$5 chip face we gotta find all the super
[ __ ] from face a Sony not doing day in
day for a while PlayStation games so
unlike Xbox games they don't plus PS now
like Xbox does with game pass
that's not Sony's focus it's not sony's
focus yet but it's clearly that they're
they're rotating the company in case
they got to go that direction holders
firing all the people that aim down at
the program shout-out to anybody that
doesn't roll with the machines rolled
over women gaming in the bill this
Streets of Rage for was only the
beginning
eventually they will have to compete
with day and date just give it time Xbox
gamepad FTW
from Hades everyone talking about PS now
hitting two billion also these in during
the pandemic however people are
comparing it to game passes ten million
but didn't these numbers come from last
year game passes now garlic I was told
that these numbers are supposed to be
announced
three or four months ago shoutout to new
rad 1991 re on machines on twitch he's
asking us if the PC users would game
past count in that total that's a good
question I'm not sure I would assume so
but don't call me I try to get some
official news whenever saw man you are
bro like where you at with this thing
man I mean it did this simple reasons
why gamepad is obviously a the better
value it would be in the lead right and
it's obviously the first party stuff day
and a it has to be like for you to even
be for the PlayStation faithful that you
really really really get behind this and
what I mean faithful I'm gonna talk
about bots but bots are gonna be mad if
if they have their first party stuff
goes in day in day just are so they get
over now
now the forget about that forget about
that the other 90 million casuals that
buy that console are gonna be elated
when when their first party stuff is in
in their day and date I don't know wait
wait wait wait time out tomorrow you
said 90 million casuals
no no you mean the hundred and twenty
because I only give five million oh like
could this ever had on 125 million sold
right they do not have millions of are
called duty go by first party purchases
so usually the first party completing
you so mister gate I will say that I
said the other night
whatever the casuals are they really
settled with the bulk of the consoles
they're going to be elated when all of
that stuff is in there dinging date
right then we also talked about the
download
downloadable aspect of it yo the only
thing you can download on PS now is ps4
games ps4 games whether they all
remasters of ps2 games or whatever you
have some of those as well it's only ps4
games on game paths you can download
every single thing every single thing
whether it's xbox back compat XP oh yeah
Xbox back compact third party games for
a party everything is downloadable so if
you don't if you have the bandwidth
you're gonna be able to play it in the
most ideal way possible that is
sovereign
are you are you server shaming them yeah
you know maybe that's something that
they would need to rectify to get in the
same league as game past now beyond that
it's just a matter of like whenever you
start talking about X cloud X cloud if
you have game past ultimate the
expectation is and we could be wrong the
expectation is they rolling that into
game pass ultimate with no additional
cost right you're gonna pay man
access to X cloud it's just a matter it
there's too many ways to engage with
game paths in a positive way and it just
isn't enough on PS now there isn't what
they do you to combat what can you do is
that that date has to be reality is you
have Xbox fans subscribing to the
service because they know look I might
not use it now but I know Microsoft's
gonna at least put games that I actually
kind of want to play to want to play I
know what dimension it's out a couple
months they're just dropping random
Triple A games in there random really
good Indies but you know the reason I
brought gaming 14 is cuz I want to know
from the retail side or is like the
retail scared of getting things like yes
I'm saying cuz technically yeah kind of
yeah against the blue and
brick-and-mortar in a sense but what do
you when it goes against it in a sense
it destroys it in a sense but I mean
overall know they actually embrace it
it's more of a it's more of a
partnership you never know what time the
what kind of conversation that backdoor
deals game stuff has with all these
different these different parties and
stuff it could be something that we
can't even fathom what's going on but
all I know is at a court
it's all about attach no matter what the
attach is if you sell a system a person
needs to buy something with it
so one of the easiest things to do
especially during this holiday you know
shout out to all the the people that's
gonna be buying these systems is how
they spit in the grip of the tax money
but uh it's really just gonna come down
to what is what was valuable to that
person that's buying the system right
then and there
do you are you buying it for yourself
are you buying it for kids and stuff
like every time somebody walks in the
door game pass for Xbox is literally the
number one thing I tell people to buy it
is it is mostly just because half the
time these people don't even know what
they're buying for people they say so
right they know so question like you go
to finish your statement up but then
after you finish testing I just want
like do you think game pass being
bundled will flecked the series acts and
whatever the series a size to come out
do you think that that's gonna be able
to elevate you know the overall sales
across or do you think it's just gonna
be something that people pick up when
they do pick up a console no I think the
it depends on how Xbox markets is like
they always did marketing and you always
had Xbox Live was always kind of tied
into the box it was never really truly
marketed on the box but they but you
everybody knew you at least got that one
month for 17 days or whatever kinda
crazy number they gave you this is the
first opportunity I feel like they have
to really step up the marketing around
what comes with the console if every box
comes with game pass on it why not put
halo infinite on the cover like it's
actually a gluten in the box with the
system because technically it is if you
buy that system day one and you have
internet capability you're gonna be able
to play those games right outside that
box instantly so this will be the first
console generation where you're gonna
get games in the box with a brand new
system and not have to buy anything
extra if you don't want to that's a huge
that's a huge selling point that I think
a lot of people are gonna be missing on
like I said I think it's gonna be a very
slow adoption rate anyway just because
these systems are going to be very very
scarce in the beginning there's gonna be
very limited yeah
it's gonna be very limited but I think
Microsoft has a really big ace in their
hole when it comes to that lock our
system where that's gonna be the system
that's gonna be available during the
holidays I think they're gonna do this
staggered launch on it and they're gonna
say hey we're gonna hit you with it
we're gonna hit you with the X we're
gonna put halo we're gonna put a pass
and everything in a box it could be
three months it could be six months I
say just do it for imagine here imagine
imagine gating game pass and you get
halo and Forza we're just buying the
console and not to mention not to
mention if the medium launches day and
day if do right what was the other the
the isometric game always about you said
no but honestly I know I know we pop and
all but my question is do you think
Microsoft really would do that that they
would like because you know the the
counter-argument is like well you're
giving away your you know I'm saying
you're exclusive sort of speaking I'm
saying do you
subscription giving them away I feel
that but do you think the script
subscription attachments a game pass is
that more important to them yes it's
literally the catalyst that's going to
push them forward mm-hmm
that is what they want to be like I mean
yeah a lot of people were a lot of
people were down in the dumps we gave
pass first got announced and they were
putting their first party gaze either
could they felt like a devalue games I
told people a long time ago I said I'm
happy they're doing this because it's
speaking to a competency dead Microsoft
always had is a company there are
software base as doing software things
they're never they've never been a
hardware company that's never been
outside the surface it that's pretty
much the most you know relevantly that
they really truly have you're outside of
Xbox never been about anything but
software so now they're diving into the
services just like they were the first
person to put an ethernet cord on the
back it wasn't because they wanted to
make their system just a better system
they wanted to get into an ecosystem
that nobody else got into which was
broadband Internet
they were the first persons to put the
external hard drive the system they say
you can you can buy it with or without
you can this is going to be the
we're gonna be able to screen assistants
to games they'd make it even better why
because they wanted their software to be
better and now they're doing the same
date 2013 yeah it sucks to go back and
listen to what actually happened there
but look where we are now
we're equally where Microsoft said we
were gonna be eight years later and
literally living that dream right now
Microsoft just had to basically put
those plans on hold and now they're
moving forward with what Jesus said the
Dreamcast pleasure to to have Ethernet
you had to buy so the place that you
know you had to buy a had land yeah let
me see a lot of you guys are forgetting
one thing
Microsoft made a deal with Samsung yes
it's still on deck the new phones when
these new systems drop the new phones
come out and you go and you pick up the
phone oh so it doesn't Microsoft a new
phone coming back out again and another
phone they announced yeah that phone is
coming up when you go and you open your
new phone you just start up in an
samsung phone and you look in the home
screen and there's a Microsoft app
that's there for gain past the branding
of game pads that logo when you see like
the Netflix and you know okay I got
Netflix you know is it's a feeling that
you feel okay good my stuff travel my
battle with you let's see the great
thing I honestly believe that's what
they trying to get that brand
recognition and and that's not counting
everybody that engages in game paths
that signs up that just uses the cloud
feature of the only phone that's the
inflate numbers astronomically well
let's leave it dive even deeper into
that can I agree 100% with you but let's
take it a step further what is what is
these what is like t-mobile at ATT and
I'm doing when it could Verizon what are
they doing with like Netflix when you
get a new subscription they give you
none like basically just give you
Netflix the HD version for free and you
don't even have to pay for let's say
when when these phones start coming out
Samsung Kies deals with the
different cellphone carriers so you
could have internet capability wherever
you go it can play all of these gay pass
games that not only work on your phone
they also work on your console because
you basically on the cross platform when
it comes to all the stuff and now you
don't even have to pay for that because
it's being subsidized by the by the
carrier Terry there's a lot of different
things that they can do to really wrap
it up what they want to so that's why ID
game pass doesn't have a price on it
they can give that thing away to
everybody because sooner or later
they're going to hit a breaking point
where the money is just going to start
pouring in on the and they're gonna get
out of the red into the black no matter
what the last one let me yeah we get the
R&B okay
knocked a pony's hat we got a $10 super
chair from R&B oh five my bad ponies
have to wait for Sony to remember PS now
exits in order for them to cat for it
now they are on Jim Jim Ryan's lap
saying no no day and super trap from
face when Sony decides to put Games Day
a day on PS now game pass will be in
relevant because he buy games and he
won't be playing that PlayStation now so
he will still go out there dating date
that's right Christopher ha standing
your Square and you go bottom games
while I'm gonna get PlayStation now imma
play just like you we got Smitty smooth
with the fight oh oh man it kicked me
back hold on man it's just funny
Smitty Smith with the $5 super chair gym
dance move Ryan and out of a twist voice
Flynn sir can we have some more servers
in Busey voice some more we got a $2
chair for Louise but we I don't even
know I ain't going try that's what all
Jim hoesley take the red pill
we caught up no we got $10 Supertramp
from gotham guy gotham guys feeding a
game pass what Alan Wake now part of it
does that this deep up the rumor of
remedy studio being acquired by Sony and
will we see a future where many title
for both systems I think so I think I
think remedy translate if you've played
control there's of this ties to Alan
Wake that suggests that Alan Wake the
sequel Alan Wake is the next game
they're working on next big game that
they're working on so yeah I could see
it coming back home we'll see but you
know yeah we got a $5 Supergirl from
stitch whoa King this is directed
towards you mmm-hmm I guess he can you
teach Christopher Hart
how does stock market works can you even
when a division is doing great the
institution may not okay so this is how
the stock market works right no it's
just really quickly um one division of
your company can be doing fantastic
which is Sony let's say Sony right so
Nizar gaming division is propping up the
company their Farrell televisions they
have fellow electronics that are self or
my laptop remember the Sony Vaio and
stuff like that so the PlayStation is
actually holding the company up right
now if that division was to fall that
will be the rest of the company that
will be defunct so right now it needs
PlayStation to be a success and when the
rest of the other parts of the company
can inflate and get better TVs will come
around once they realize what they're
doing wrong so homes will come around I
doubt it um that's a that's a dead
market for them laptops will come around
when they actually get it together but
they have to diversify you are
absolutely right one division can be
doing better while the company as a
whole has a complete sickness this is
true no pics a bit G with the file off
super chat the first 210 million wins a
console ringing Peter Waze the cloud
console race might be over Oh
I don't even know if that console metric
is is valid anymore I mean again Sony's
gonna use console numbers right
Microsoft is not unless they absolutely
happen to be destroying so anyway I
don't know this Goods gonna happen play
um and you know that would be they would
be put up for scrutiny if they did that
because they refused to do it when they
were losing that's why I want them to
stay quiet on that we got we got a we
got a five dollar super try from R & B
no Xbox game pass on every Samsung
device and TV going forward remember
this quote green so then we got a five
dollar super chair from Smitty Smitty
just want to say it's always a pleasure
to support IOP log my aunt kos and the
last word so hard man let's get some
shells in there another thing we didn't
talk about is how game pass has become
this platform for the it for indie
titles now right and that's another
thing that Pierce now wasn't doing
that's why I'm back in it back when they
said that Yoshida's role had shifted and
changed he was focusing on indie and I
said they're not gonna go big first
party titles day and date but I think
they realized that they do have to give
more value for PS now for people who are
actually in how do you do that okay you
start bringing in small Indies day and
date right give give that back amount of
value to to the subscription service so
I think you're working on that I think
anything any indie sort of deals that
they have in the works he's going in day
and date on PS now the students in the
office that has no chairs the regime
that is soon to be phased out the only
reason why he has been out there like
he's he's part of the old regime but he
got in line no like I'm about to say the
only reason why he is not out the door
is because he started bending the knee a
little bit
ain't you [ __ ] knees down then he can
get a chair back standing in a corner
look out the wall
so you know this topics been amazing but
I really want to get to the next to our
chat Lord let me yes ed took the round
good day fan good to see you a good help
brother brother from twitch new red 1990
he's saying electronics and games one
third of sorting prophets private
insurance is just over one half of Sony
profit so it's which that's what you say
it shout to John it did be all back good
to see you brother sony face out here
still le never lost big ball of a super
chart from 108 a shot at the King shout
out to Dave it's chaos is now king of 4k
fax Rosie don't look I swear get these
balls off
real quick cuz I gotta give it up to a
Phil Dominus right now you gotta give
them as little role his name for 10
minutes max max Massoud severe Ilyas as
King said look man you know let's just
let's just open up the book X right
quick because he dropped some body he
literally said this was when a 2019
interview with the verge he says selling
a lot of consoles is good of course for
bragging rights and revenue he said but
the real money comes from software and
services he said the business is not
about how many consoles you sell the
business is how many players are playing
the games that they buy how they play he
said I think it's from the easy from the
outside to judge the health of our
business around how many consoles any
company sells in the end he said how
many subscribers you have to something
like game pass how many games people are
buying those are much better metrics on
the health of the business and
historically consoles are sold at a loss
I want you to watch over you
what you do and it has come to fruition
if you boys don't get in line it was the
book of excess weight tearing you up to
be said pass the collection plate he do
not care about you still in 125 you know
why cuz his bucks is still good baby not
getting into overalls for less than 400
I said where look also all due success
to position now they are growing and
obviously we do see what game pass is
moving and grooving out here it's gonna
be a good next generation just two
different approaches we got to see how
this thing gonna pop off so let's get
into the next topic
what's goin on wit bow your heads and
pray I had to give you a book of X
without love a filler have bars with
every show so Lord addict man you are up
what is going on is a lot of talk about
reveal events what date is what for who
what was going on man you know why I'm
gonna let you pop this off you know for
what we heard obviously initially was
dead I believe was this specific man you
know obviously some news came out and
initially everyone was kind of saying
it's gonna be a specific date June 4th
this was a PS 5 reveals gonna come it's
supposed to be you know a lot of things
information so right now it has been
confirmed that it's not happening you
know I'm saying and they say the insider
is now saying the information will be
revealed only in August and that's much
later than anticipated so that was kind
of the first thing so definitely right
now from what we hear in know June event
on PlayStation 5 and then I just wanted
to bring some to the attention I think
it was my man - Jeff Grubb um he
basically says something very insightful
he basically said I wouldn't expect
console prices until August he said when
Intel Nvidia and AMD launch similar
products he said they will wait until
the last possible minute to set a price
you said he said that's the only thing
that can still change but he said of
course consoles still relying on
pre-orders for that price set whatever
so it's a lot of chest won't know a lot
of moving is shaken but things have
changed so I want to give it back to you
attic about the initial date you know
the June 4th thing and then you know
what's going on now possible orders so
you know on uh on on the epic June the
4th that's been that the definitive time
where this is happening everybody
definitely go on June the 4th it's
happening hundred percent there's no
dying so you know definitely on June the
4th they're supposed to be revealed then
from insiders will just say that and
what the biggest questions I want to ask
is what type of reveal do you expect and
what type of games would you expect at
that reveal because I think you could go
either way
Sony is the type of person to be like
you'll just throw everything out there I
don't care throw everything out there
show them what we do in this whole
generation like cuz you'll think they
pretty much did that with this they in
like 2014 they literally showed every
game that's coming out for like the next
five years right besides like gosu
Kashima which came out like and they
showed that what three years ago like
King Maurer let's hang up basket kid all
Forte so what are you thinking about the
the the fluid nature of these release
dates next gen event dates so
the price of like look they're not gonna
really I don't think they're gonna talk
about really anything until they're
ready to give that price out and right
now they're still playing cat and mouse
with Microsoft now I believe price
matters more to Sony than it does to
Microsoft because Microsoft is I think
they're they're willing to let that
system sit at $500 whoa PlayStation on
the other hand they don't want to be in
a bidding war with a less powerful
system at the same price and in repeat
what happened to 2013 yeah the
Playstations gonna have different
abilities and it's gonna have things
that it does a little bit better than
the Xbox but overall when people look at
the system they're gonna look at a
weaker version of the system no matter
what no matter how you slice it so Sony
has definitely they're basically looking
like okay if Sony Microsoft's gonna come
out with this system and we have nothing
to combat it especially if they got a to
system attack right they're waiting to
see what's gonna play out here Sony is
also in a situation where they're
looking at we're a worldwide bland no
matter what happens we're gonna sell our
systems no matter what people keep
thinking that August is too late I even
talked about this on braaap a couple
weeks ago for month it if they were in
or if they release information in August
about pre-orders and how much the
system's gonna cost and they see it's
coming in in October if they put those
pre rup next week those systems will be
sold out anyway yeah cuz cuz people
people are gonna buy them up no matter
what so price and stuff really doesn't
matter I mean really doesn't matter on
both sides at all but if Sony wants to
UM have a chance to combat with
Microsoft's gonna do they have to take
this wait-and-see approach right so
there's really no way around it I know
people want to hear what Sony has to say
they want to see the system and I get
that but they're looking at like hey
Microsoft has a very long term plan in
place when it comes to how they want to
attack this generation and Sony from
everything I've been hearing is a little
bit stagnant because of everything
that's been happening with with the
virus to shake-up of the company
movement all over the place and they
really don't know they did a guy hit
what a haymaker
in December that they didn't expect so
that kind of threw everything you know
it's a into like this frenzy that
they've just been reacting to whole
generate like the whole last seven
months I think they want to get back on
their terms they wonder if they want to
dictate to Microsoft instead of be a
dictate to me and that will start when
they finally know what the price of this
system is gonna be then they could come
out and say we're gonna come out of
dollars cheaper and if they want to
actually eat that bullet which I don't
think they will but it just helps them
it's basically just gonna help them you
know support what they want to do going
forward and everything like that but
it's not gonna really hurt them
overall but they can't wait to August
legit okay I think they will fair enough
kids movement what do you think about
this moving and shaking next gen reveal
events you know the Sony event not being
the June 4th or whatever and you know
everything with the positioning with
both companies um I got two films about
what I think is a mistake and because
we're looking at a time where if
PlayStation is to do finally to be
reveal in August we would know obviously
what the Xbox Series X look like what
the piece is what the release date is
with some of the games already demoing
at all before we got a PlayStation 5
image so and the other things it's like
okay they can pull it Apple Apple
doesn't build reveal their phone in
September and then LLL blow and sell in
October right so I mean it's PlayStation
really there are like is in the nature
of like you know information we're in
the middle of the summer we want games
it's like do you how long do you hold
out because Microsoft even though
they're doing things new they're still
playing by old school rules meaning
alright we have a timeline I released
reveal this reveal this and then at this
day we're gonna talk about price and
release it you can pre-order and stuff
like that right um I prefer obviously at
this point I prefer to Microsoft way it
sucks when you know these things are
coming right this is your five why are
you gonna show the controller and you're
gonna way all the way to August to show
the console along
it's we know it's there I mean obviously
there's content if they're truly relying
on third party for launch they got a one
of the rumors right like the one of the
rumors now is that things are not as
hefty with the soft the Sony software a
lineup the places if our software lineup
is another rumor that we're hearing in
conjunction with every continued
continued kick honestly I feel like if
I've been leaning on this thing could
potentially be delayed to like early
2021 I mean it just it just fills it
doesn't kill my can definitely agree
with you I feel like for some reason the
way expose me I feel like they're coming
earlier than expected
oh like PlayStation is come in later
than oh but that's awesome get your ball
go first a little bit different keep it
a buck I think price matters to
Microsoft I think it does I think when
you look at this past generation when
you look at when you look at day one
right all the negative press around Xbox
coming into the the launch of the Xbox
one by the time that console actually
launched most of that most of that was
done with most of that was gone like if
you're if you were if you a hardcore
person like us you knew that a lot of
that was thrown off the table right so
the only difference the biggest
difference that matters to the vast
majority of consumers right is the price
point to mean is that price point and
obviously if they do have this to
counsel approach
they have leeway there right they have
leeway yeah they have that pincer
approach where they where they draw them
in and then pinch of them and sword
winterkill box and and the thing about
it is I just think to me when Phil said
we will not be meek you're going to be
bold to me that says that whatever
they're gonna wait
as possible to give you the price if at
all possibly gonna wait for Sony to go
first
right and honestly I think because we
you talk about pocket watching this than
the other but if there's any company of
the two that has real leeway about
eating eating loss on the console it's
them
so he really really wants to make a
point he couldn't he could at the last
be like no this is what the price is
gonna be and it's gonna be whatever $100
less than the PlayStation pretty all
that in PlayStation um you know again
that's to the mo - Kai me thinking
nothing I figure I guess my question you
solve is what about when do we hit that
proverbial wall where it's like your fam
both of you I gotta give this price that
so wait wait wait this is the ultimate
game of chicken kinda right yeah so like
right when is when do we get to that
point wears like yo somebody gotta go
first I think it definitely is August to
me because of the high everything has
changed there's no relaxed 23 and
especially how um you know summer game
fest is being spread out like that so it
you're expecting news throughout the
summer into it like early fall right
yeah I would say they're both gonna hold
out price-wise until August so I think
we could get a reveal for both consoles
we're getting ready
it may hold down on price Jake so he
could afford to show the console do
everything and it still be like you're
weighing ready ain't getting that price
for it because they're gonna come out
and they're gonna show and this is why
they've been quiet to me they've never
traditionally they've never had the
greatest of launch lineups right right
where's where's next box oh you know in
terms of you know they had a party over
there crazy if you look at their launch
lineups they had resistance at ps3's
launch
yes Tekken Tag in a couple of other side
so titles it's what Italy gear they have
nor do they have not had where Microsoft
apart three silver months with a markets
all apart from the 360 winning and they
did have perfect target just wasn't the
greatest game buddy right there they've
always had a big first party title at
the launch of their consoles yeah so at
least one so just just a tie or two
what he was just talking about the only
thing I think can really cuz I do think
price matters more than Sony and you're
right Xbox kidding Microsoft could
definitely eat the pill when it comes to
that dollar I don't think nobody wants
to eat money but but if Sony if we get
to like July you talk about that
breaking point if we don't hear
something about a reveal rivet from Sony
by July like the middle of July that's
this is gonna get delayed it to next
year and the reason I think it's gonna
get delayed into the beginning of next
year is it's not about them being ready
to release the system I think they're
ready to release it I think they want to
hit a certain price point and with
everything that's going on and
manufacturing prices being through the
roof right now on some of this stuff
they're saying hey if we release this
system in the in the spring instead of
the winner those prices will come down
and we could probably make up that fifty
extra dollars or a hundred dollars in
difference that this going on right now
there's a whole bunch of different ways
to think but if we don't get it revealed
by July and talking about August that
systems not coming out this year boy
what a they did in their most recent
earnings report said that they still say
the PlayStation 5 is on schedule
so you going against the Saudi how many
times have you heard a coroner's report
come by they say well we overestimated
and all of a sudden that earnest record
get cut down for the first quarter of
the next year recently sure they thought
they were gonna sell a whole bunch of
systems and then all of a sudden it was
like naw fair we overshot that came out
of you later
a hundred bucks of more expenses like
we're not a lot of software oh I don't
know that they can afford that this time
because they I mean as great of a name
relating they working off the ps4 name
and what is done I just don't know
because Microsoft is in a better
position this time right my phone
so I don't think it's
gonna be a full year delay it could be
five four or five months we'll put them
in February right well put them in
February but this is where I kind of
side with you fort a we've had this
discussion offline which is I think it's
imperative for Microsoft to be out first
like yes if you're out for cuz I one of
the mistakes I feel that don't nee don't
know one talk everyone talks about 2013
this is how you train use games TV TV t
we all admit that had it downfall but
the thing that people don't mention
enough I feel is when the Xbox one
launch it only launch in a few
territories and I mean that was a major
mistake and out from what I've heard
from the manufacturer and things of this
nature they plan on doing a proper
global launch from my understanding with
the series x which i think is a huge
boost because you can't just launch any
few territories and expect to dominate
globally and you ain't when you ain't
everywhere to be picked up you know
there so I mean there's also you know
it's a big thing but at the same time at
the same time talk like it doesn't
matter as much if they launch globally
hardware wise because they have game
paths and you're gonna have halo day and
date on a PC let me go King will get his
balls off Smitty Smith real quick bow
your heads and pray don't book of a
Dragon Lord so I'm gonna need one of
those jerseys faster brother speak the
King on it as exclusive that's pretty I
don't know if you ready for that wall
Tom Brady price jersey right there
Jonathan B just so y'all know my xbox
just caught the Holy Ghost from that way
God in there we gotta give a little God
a bill we got it
it was wo guy from shrink Kingdom bad
news how do you know how do you show C's
s with no price I think when they show
the gas they're gonna show the price yes
Allah know the realm is waiting for
yours Midway monster what if I'll also
be tell it's just Joel price of the
series s to make so nice corner
especially since it's going to be less
than a PS 5 anyway we got a $5 super
trap from restored Hades a little Sony
my son II might have a limited amount of
consoles PS fans really think the
majority of those consoles are going to
stay in the east
Stoney's focus is the east ooh
interesting how we caught up no we got
another photo super trap from restored
Hades Sony's first party devs just
dropped gains the PlayStation was an
actual horse it would break late in the
race not bring and not bring out the
gate that's true no that sounds
arranging for everybody trying to get
these jerseys fan you need to speak the
king that's an exclusive situation yeah
I don't sell those I just got a puppet
remembrance for my there we go mortal
Azam but look King they won't get you
get your balls off you know I'm saying
as far as this situation man where you
at release dates next generation events
you know I'm saying wait were you out
with this man 6 for 2020 oh you goo fees
were standing on that square now yeah
like Q Bert long it is my god a lot of
you Goofy's was standing on that square
now you're like Qbert and it's square is
no longer dead that's old gaming bars
think about that mm-hmm
a lot of you dudes on your shows talking
about your head inside information and I
was laughing at Johnny I was laughing at
you Goofy's I knew what was going on Oh
Lord and then y'all missed the mark the
mark ain't even here yet oh and he told
you not fam that's not a good mark for
you
you ran your mouth that's not a good
mark for you okay Daniel was with this
hyperbole you're gonna show them a bunch
of games and all these guys is gonna be
shown oh you're gonna see real gameplay
trailer dude it's gonna be really yeah
you're gonna with the next generation of
doom bro yo temper those expectations we
got a lot of third parties and go him
sprinkle in a bunch the JPEGs okay at
what point in time do you realize
something's wrong I've been screaming
something was wrong since January oh
I've been telling you damn near every
show something is wrong see y'all just
started dating huh
we just started great we've been doing
this girl we video this girl since she
was born like you just got her now when
she's able to go out and hang a little
bit we knew she this is different she
not too saying she's switching up on you
my balls are no longer the same she's
not looking the same
she's the perfume will smell the same
way she got meat that's at the time of
play she said she's leaving you're she's
leaving your techsan seem like she hears
you spit in his bar but she's leaving
you on seeing you're claiming this girl
but she's not claiming you and I'm
trying to figure out for the life of me
why are you guys so afraid of just going
with the other better-looking chick like
you don't own no claims on her she's not
coming to next year I told y'all before
I thought it's gonna be delayed one they
don't move like this too when you
have a good first party game to launch
what your system see now you're hoping
that gran turismo will be that launched
Gran Turismo is never gonna be on it's
never known granted
we already know of polyphony whatever
that name is of their company Paulo
fighting but never they games take
forever
right there perfectionist right so you
know one Sony if sony's gone by the old
model they're never going to put a game
of that caliber on a launch lineup
because they want to have at least ten
million before that game is released so
they can have at least four million so
to show good numbers they still showing
face all right so you have to understand
that game incoming so it has to be a
game that's old but new but still part
of the catalogue that they can just
throw out there that's gonna sell I
don't know if they have that game yet
but to Forte's were cheap prices is hot
yeah and we know their pockets is funny
they can't afford the ring up they don't
have it they never showed you a console
you don't have money to get for you
don't have the cash for mock up you
really think they're gonna tell you
yo we got this dude they don't got
nothing but King I love her damn I won't
marry her
listen listen she don't want marry you
next year you're gonna get you're gonna
get the system next year right and
you're gonna get a proper lineup next
year your forte be a very disrespectful
thing no we're not we're just being
realistic that's the only thing they
actually said they coming out this year
okay card okay how many times have we
said that we've won promises you she
belongs yours three beloved good god how
many times have people said they going
with a featuring
they wait they wait everything is booked
up they don't show up right
we know those duels that's down for the
get-down already done everything is
already done so when you're ready you're
ready mm-hmm you can show stuff you had
they had a mock up at the Game Awards
you saw a breakdown later on in the next
year listen man one company is ready and
one company isn't and I don't want y'all
to feel like okay yo King is raining on
my parade right now though he's gonna be
game play let's the system will come out
it's not coming out when you want it and
no matter how hard you kick and scream
you're not gonna stop xbox from doing
what they're doing but at the same time
I just want you guys to be a little bit
more realistic and look at it how I'm
seeing it I have the same stuff you have
I purchased the same stuff you purchase
with stuff for PlayStation now but what
I'm seeing is somebody isn't ready and
the other people already okay and
they're showing me I'm more confident in
one person launching in the other person
not listen I feel that part that part on
which as far as the readiness and almost
like the kid who's ready to take the
test you know he's studying prepared
fillers out here I get that part now in
let's play fair what about because they
know Sony
I mean Microsoft is so prepared right
and they like look we can't bust off
just yet these dudes is ready for us to
come outside so let's just wait to the
very last minute right because two parts
it's a marketing thing let's just say
definitively as it seems to be the
definitive thing that the series X is
more powerful I know we can talk SSDs
and performance and all that we'll get
there I'm not gonna touch that you know
that's another argument all I'm gonna
say is that definitively most are saying
that the series X is the more powerful
machine so I'm a marketing standpoint
right I can understand marketing saying
yo hold the brakes cuz we got to come up
with how we going finesse as far as
because you always got to make your
system attractive to the man
right so maybe changes maybe fastest and
games is the joint right fascist the
games that's the the new just like I see
them holding back on that and then let's
just be real like like if if what you
said is true what solve is saying is
true that the price that Microsoft film
dominant Spencer is willing to whatever
your price is he gonna cut right so what
if they say to themselves hey yo let's
take it to the higher-ups and say yo
let's do this 400 we will take the loss
but we cannot be Oh same price is only
outside outside of the ps4 they have so
consoles at a loss before they have sort
of manner wonderful so let's just say
that they say you know we got to take
the loss because you don't think so not
that loss I think I think back then they
could yes I said thank you Eric for
saying that because the health of the
company is not the same that it was back
then when they were able to do so oh
this is very dependent on a price point
that is affordable palatable and they
can also make something if they're gonna
lose they don't want to lose more often
I think I think the most they'll do is
break even like I think they'll get to
the point they're like let's literally
sell it for what it cost us to make me
ask this to the relishes get straight to
it
are y'all telling me roundtable that
there is no scenario yah see Sony can't
drop that 400 price I don't think if
they do could be cheaper for me to buy
the series X you know stakes
I just might pay I think the stakes are
that high they know Microsoft is ready
they know Microsoft is coming so I think
maybe you gotta go over the top that's
not they might know a bunch of stuff but
they showed us anything let me let me
ask you a question cog these over it
everybody all here let's get it which
system is more likely to sell the more
peep - both - both clients xbox or
playstation playstation so let me ask
you this why would a playstation know
could they know this trust me they know
that more people we'd be even if a
person buys an Xbox a PlayStation it is
probably still in there for you
that's just how most gamers roll
compared to some people buy a
Playstation and never buy an xbox that's
just how it is but if Sony knows that
and they already know they can't win
this price battle with Microsoft this
year then they want to take it they want
to take five months and say we're gonna
push this thing out and see if the price
on these components come down so we
don't have to eat that price that we are
naked we're gonna have to eat but we're
still gonna sell the system people are
still gonna buy the system they came out
a year later in 2007 what a ridiculous
price on the system right it still ended
up coming back and beat next you know
exercise one but it still happens yeah
but that's why that's why I keep telling
people it's like no matter what happens
here Sony is gonna end up probably
selling more systems but it's all about
the perception of what Xbox is doing to
be aggressive this generation they're
gonna be so aggressive they got Sony
thinking we're not gonna release the
system probably this year due to the
price that we don't want to be the same
price as a system that technically is
more power than us and we can't get the
price point we want if they're thinking
that they in the long term they're gonna
sell more consoles in them anyway don't
you think that same thinking applies and
every like you know what doesn't matter
or the matter we delay or not if we we
come out with them and we're still gonna
beat them on a namer role in global
Brandon's but then it come out but then
they might have more games first party
games ready around that time - it's more
of a powerful statement to sit there and
say it's more of an arrogance move put
it this way if Sony as we all know Sony
can be arrogant this is gonna be more of
a power play saying it does not matter
what you do when it comes to releasing
your system you could come out six
months seven months earlier but as long
as we have the games and we have the
price we're gonna catch you no matter
what we gotta say we're all saying that
the price will not be
y'all don't see them well I just will
fall if they allow manufacturing to get
itself under control again I know you
think five or six months is gonna give
you enough of a break yes yes yes do we
really think even with manufacturing at
its normal rate that they still can hit
a 400 price point like 100 instead of
500 if it goes above board they're going
to 5 I guarantee they're not going to
450 for 25 or 35 they're going in five
didn't they say that manufacturing at
this point is about 450 450 without the
actual production like the d5 I'm sorry
like I know people think it's that they
have that that dream that it's gonna be
for if it's for that's great because I
could pick up premium marketing dough
for the holiday though you got to
remember when they tie that extra 50
bucks in there that's part of holiday
marketing which is a premium during that
time of year you released it during our
off-peak time like Nintendo did when you
don't even have to do will you do a lot
of marketing but not as much money has
to go into it you may see 20 to 30
dollars per system on that right yeah
you know that Forte that they're not
fighting for space during their holiday
season for show specie when when you
start to fight for shelf space during a
holiday season you have to pony up cash
I give you ant your stuff in front of
the store it's you know it's different
prices right like for companies that if
they pay a certain price your stuff is
the first thing they see when they come
inside a store right like Nintendo
literally pays for premium spot when you
first walk in a store when you see
Nintendo at the front door they paid to
be right at the front door and they send
representatives out to each and every
store see if their stuff is in place
product placement is very key you know
and financially I'm
okay y'all think that I'm I'm down and
on Sony but not to do their likes the
popular do like I don't care about I
never liked George I never liked his
ball hey so listen let me tell you some
I'd never did no longer gay shut up mr.
ha no it's sort of the only time I cop
Jordan will he had a 45 and he was a bum
right now is Jordan let's keep it up on
women
I'm just waiting for the 45 wait we got
a finally exclusive Jersey for exclusive
talent and brother of the round
we got a what's it you have to talk to
King we got a two dollar super choc from
drunken ninja Sony waiting for this Tim
Smitty Smith first the PS fanboys was
playing q0 Bert but Q Bert now they
playing Frogger getting ran over spot
car trucker hat hollow but did she wear
trucker you say okay let me get body I
don't know pop I also checked kick
sounded like Leonidas at 300 we're
speaking to the Arcadian then he brought
more soldiers that they did tell okay we
got a 69 for two dollars a week FM
states how are you going to use the SST
window I can't you got a rate you you
got a rechristen for heart cuz easy oh
dude okay somehow I can't see it right
mega that dish
good good the voluntary attack devs love
that ps5 SSD fam sorry to say you just
say something about this talking about
this if multi-party games is going to be
played on a PC now every pc has an SSD
they don't care about your fast
quickness they don't care about it it
doesn't matter it doesn't produce
graphics it doesn't produce CPU power
all it is is a fast little engine now if
it's built for everything and the SSD is
exclusive ok it's exclusive so you must
wait for Sony to put first party games
that can only take advantage of the SSD
listen to this you have not seen that
one first party game maybe they can't
even control it you don't know how to
juggle you said listen it's an either
power or performance power or
performance but we can get it there fast
right so they did they're fast juggler
with bad coordination we gotta fight all
the super transfer takes a bit so it is
good to sell you less power for 500
because they have huge community a huge
community happy to still still for them
oh okay
I think it happened to 2013 we gotta
find on the super track from drunken
engines that's why game passes the
golden ticket
you won't have to drop the 60 to 120 on
new games that launch got a point
no down by dollar super champ from you
guys can read that when we get soft if
the Xbox is finalized what do you think
about both next-gen systems that have
high NPC stats really cause they at
least 500 both of them King on speed
back ok did you get your boss I'm sorry
brother did you get your balls off for
this real quick or name with a move
and now we we about the pricing yeah it
was 4years yeah yeah no no we know I
went up before come on bad I wasn't so
bad I'll say my job look man I hate
everything I say in it ain't nobody
saying that that's not possible and
here's the stemple sorry to cognate this
is gonna be a hot summer and I'm I'm hi
listen for the but listen for the bad
bro like listen shout out to Jeff grub
man cuz he he nailed it he was just like
look they are gonna both are gonna hold
out on this price to the woman who
longer than oh listen I think I think
what we got a chill we're trying to you
know narrow in you know hard and fast
dates I think this situation is very
fluid especially with Sony so we know we
know Microsoft is coming with day days
there you know a dates your man that's
been missing the marks you go I dig it's
three things here I think we got that
you know we got the pandemic which
throws everything in the loop and then I
heard what a pandemic only work for one
couple moves
I know his moves I see his one two step
with the drink in his hand
I'm not gonna load I'm gonna say that
the third party reveal Bay a bit
affected by Mike Microsoft with the
pandemic I don't think I don't think it
increased the height but I don't think
it hurt to meet it right but all I'm
trying to say is when you have
situations like that the other side can
look and say oh they slip right there
there's a banana peel okay make sure we
don't do that right but these come out
no no absolutely
I'm so into your defense right Mac sauce
out here in the street Phil's out here
movable it is like oh we got something
and then we got a controller right now
so again it works what I'm trying to say
is this is this is not a controller
computer console right where did Sony
announced that it was actually coming
out this holiday when did they say ps5
was less
out of here to these build the business
insider let's just check this out and
basic again the reporter says only did
confirm doing its most recent earnings
report that the plant is still the loss
of PS five when was the original time
that they announced that no like when
would like we knows Microsoft said it
basically in December when it Sony first
say it I don't know when they first said
it I just know now what did they say it
after so after Microsoft we got that way
and now this is Zoe's May 21st when
right so let me so let's put a tinfoil
hat on on this though Microsoft
Microsoft came out and basically poo
pooed on their parade by saying they're
coming out basically this holiday they
said they showed the system at the game
awards yes Sony was like what the hell
they stood at his holiday Sony was like
we weren't coming out into the beginning
of could remember a lot of people were
rumor in the first quarter of 2020 ones
for PlayStation right Dave Dave was like
okay can we move up manufacturing to get
this system out earlier they probably
said yeah we can they committed to that
guess what happened korone that will
virus has right shut down their
manufacturing that put them back on
their timetable where there's like well
we wanted to come out this year but we
can't now right
Microsoft has always been planning for
this year right they been playing for
this year since the middle of last year
that's why they were that's why they
were willing that date out there at Mike
that's why they were willing to put that
date out the or put that window out
there dairy Christmas right Sony has
been reacting to everything Microsoft
has been doing ever since that day so so
it's just a simple fact that I just
believed that Sony wants to release that
system this year right but due to
everything going on they can't get the
manufacturing prices out under control
they can't get everybody on these shows
say for the last four months with Sony
kept a mouth shut
they better tool right well B would be
truthful
come on doesn't listen when people was
out here hearing all this other stuff
y'all still would have been out here
slandering come on let's be for real
be king because I'm a controller I was
slandering them in anyway when they told
you that they was coming on June 4th
I was slandering listen listen I know
for a couple I'd known a couple of
things right but the funny part about it
is one thing I don't know listen I do
not know there's no inside information I
do not know that they're going to be
held back it's just my field types eNOS
you will forte on that square all I'm
saying is again I would find it very
surprising that an earnings report again
yes do things change this thing fluid
yeah I just would find it surprising
that it don't it don't drop now as far
as the holding back to your question
Forte I do believe that was a
reactionary they've been reactive since
the game Awards since the game Awards
since the series X drop since the
hell-blade all that since the what is it
the digital foundry to you whatever the
other dude is Microsoft has been so
aggressive with sure what they have
right then it has forced them to say yo
let us chill that's big think about that
too right they came out and said that
day real date they were forced into
showing us the control correct they they
showed that off early right what are you
talking about early you showed it
when did they show that controller off
was March yeah yeah where did we first
hear about when did they start talking
architecture for the PlayStation and all
the other stuff they talk about that in
February of the year that they released
it so you're telling me that you were
forced to release information on a
controller two months after you even
talked about this you would even talk to
really about the system so why would we
think that this is actually something
that they were ready for they look this
whole like you said this whole situation
has been fluid right all this year they
are did they're basically trying they're
basically trying to take this
wait-and-see approach to see I just had
Epiphany go ahead I think they're
waiting for PlayStation Alice's to get a
little bit higher listen to me right
okay so since since we
well the old number but Microsoft game
passes at 10 million right and is only
gonna increasing growth throughout the
year right that's how the projections go
right okay so let's say Microsoft by the
time that the series X launches game
passes probably at like 20 million right
now that's conservative estimate right
because I think they're closer to 20 the
closer to 15 million now than they were
at 10 but let's let's say that part
right those are customers that are
transferring over every person that
purchase a series X is a game pass
customer because I believe it's going to
be in the box I believe they can give
that away because they want you on the
service with all as to what right now
let's say Sony Figg figures out that
they can subsidize some of the cost of
the system by making sure that every
subscriber that has a PlayStation 4
PlayStation 5 has PlayStation now what
do you do during the meantime you make
PlayStation mount now more palatable
more affordable and also more inviting
right by putting games and maybe this is
the time that they announce day and day
show games stuff like that and this is
what you be able to take home with
because I can't see Microsoft is the
only one that's inside the store going
home with a service in games and not
having to purchase anything else and I
thinks PlayStation 5 can benefit from
that same thing but I think maybe they
want to get the numbers just a little
bit more so they can so they can make
more money off of the services when they
sell your PlayStation 5 so they have
five million out they have five million
sold give you a service they do what I
say they need to do not do it is built
listening you are trying to apply
Microsoft philosophies or so they still
have a gym dance move right little fill
but that's definitely showing you that
he's willing today but it takes it takes
time for people to adopt the full
philosophy fully they still been
hesitant to put their foot all the way
in the pool and say y'all we're giving
first party first date they like look we
gonna let y'all we're gonna put some
older stuff in there let y'all rock what
Microsoft is doing is forcing their hand
to get better but I don't think they're
really the dive in the pool all I'm
trying to say is
philosophies also we got stop acting
Forte like they dominate the last
generation so they are on their own
timetable the price thing is a issue
because to you what's the difference why
are you gonna waste six months to
release the console right it throughout
the course of the release of the console
the manufacturer calls them go down
anyways so why wait for six month if
price didn't matter why didn't they
release P in 2013 just lead to connect
the camera stuff in the box and release
at the same prices the Xbox it come out
of the same like dude right now if they
release that system at the same time as
they release that Xbox right that's
gonna be $500 okay what does it matter
you take the L now or you take it out
later yeah it's still the same no it's
not the same l if you ain't spending
more money but I tell you if I tell you
that hey wait six months every system
that you produce you're gonna save a
hundred dollars on it by waiting six
months
what's go what are you gonna do so over
you will see where you go just to get
just of just to smite your face what's
more important coming at $500 or lower
come to the market first willingly let's
Microsoft have the thing y'all
forgetting again we still have that
generation for them to end they got a
whole victory lap of go see Tsushima and
last of us to get that mark they don't
technically wanna let you kind of know
about PlayStation 5 in a way because dis
erase they still got money to cash it on
that's what I'm trying so that's why
July is the cutoff point runs go sistema
comes out and if we still don't hear
about place I'm witty now that's what I
told me on this I said you'll July if at
that point we still not hearing nothing
about that
I'm absolutely what you thought a yo
this thing might not come out this year
because at that point we supposed to
have her stuff you don't got all your
balls off with PlayStation 4 we got it
you don't saying you victory lap last
year the race GG a 2019 champion of the
year nothing like the old postman all
right if I don't hear something about
this date
tell you what it is we're in this
situation that question why fanboys like
to claim funds they don't get a good at
PS 5 is 9.2 but now they pushed it the
developers and others are trying to
reset take advantage of the booth Sony
is not ready for launch
ok do we get one oh wait before it's
gonna be hot summer man that's all over
there we got promote
we got Aaron summers with the 2 pounds
who pitch at absolutely love this
podcast salute the iron Lord Rhodes
Luke Luke I'm going blind over here two
wizards anyone dish with the $10 super
chat grace sure Laura's like every week
keep up the good work podcast is the
highlight of my week bless it's a little
oh I think slow is a video better
[Laughter]
was that like a person in like a big
kachou costume it was writ to say
something like hey slow well here's some
ammunition I know you go needs to keep
the numbers they will they will lose
money on a system if it helps convert
numbers in the long term thank you miss
this holiday window oh they love us a
little bit your shout to my last word
brother Eve artist or this Twitter easly
see you brother
thanks for the boys it's a fun dig man
it's gonna be a fun I can't wait kids
summer people you're going to have a
very terrible summer like one team is
gonna be running around the streets
acting crazy and the other team is gonna
be you looking for cyberpunk 2077 they
won that bend the knee cause you gonna
be shipping his knees out and I'm gonna
have the barbecue sauce man I'm just I'm
just gonna mount your knees I'm not
going not melted nothing on me so
there's rumors of a PlayStation 5 Silent
Hill it exists apparently there's a
Silent Hill
demo apparently that is going to be
shown sort of whatever in conjunction
from from PlayStation but there's been a
lot of different rumors that Kojima was
involved and that's kind of debunked
there have been rumors that it's gonna
be something in the vein of all kind of
like some arg stuff where they like the
game is gonna be
all on your phone and and and accessing
your internet oh oh yeah I don't need
that level of intrusion yeah yeah so I
don't know what's true or not but
apparently the last rumor is that it is
kind of a reboot it is in a third person
game sort of in the vein of what we've
seen in the reboots of res evil
um so we'll see I love Silent Hill I
think it's a perfect companion to res
evil it's a lot weirder Silent Hill 2 is
one of my favorite games of all time so
we'll see
thou shalt Yvonne says I want to get his
bars off from twitch long-term
investment is a big deal as I pop in for
a few seconds Microsoft has the purse to
lose money if they want to go for the
knockout but Sony knows how important
PlayStation is to the and he's got to
finish his boss there but look I agree
man it's gonna be exciting with the old
gene isn't it not let this that old
topic go shout out the gene file at 6
Tyler super chat I'm trying to cut the
podcast revolver Silent Hill is
absolutely happening when where there's
fire there's fire I can't tell you if
it's gonna be next week or 2023 don't we
see Resident Evil 8 and Silent Hill next
week so yeah man is this is it's gonna
be a lot of things cooking up a lot of
rumors man fantastic fantastic show
y'all we got to get out here cuz it has
been crazy long let's get this poll
poppin a little fun so new ILP poll this
week with the recent NPD group tracking
monthly says Final Fantasy 7 remake as
the best-selling name of April 2020 and
the third best selling game of the year
which of these games do you think ends
up as the best-selling game of 2020 they
calling it calling a lord King cyberpunk
2077 be animal crosses new horizon see
once you put it Lord attic or name today
Lord addicts Animal Crossing new horizon
or see Last of Us 2 or D I don't care
Final Fantasy 6 is still to go
shoutout to baby being besties it's
continued to to put the pressure on
final fantasy this might be the only
week where I think that fourth one might
one obsolete pleasure to read let's get
some shout outs been lowered kids school
Lord gay before it's a up in the realist
or over kiss will the Conqueror of last
of us with the boss collected checks out
here doin it big wicked afar people
finds what you got going on sir hey man
find me on Twitter um on YouTube both
have grown tremendously over the past
two weeks I'm at kids move on Twitter in
the kiss move on YouTube also check out
what come on a night like that comes
definitely going weapon world for it
that's yeah yeah and hey other
controversies I'm not I'm not running
away from anything so look forward to
that keep Tom you guys got all podcast I
love it thank you brother always love
you always disappoint from day one
always love man we've been working on
the show floor together there's always
love man so Luke to you and continue
doing your thing I know I'm gonna listen
in to hear you get your balls off it's
gonna be funny shout out to Lord gaming
Forte so many podcast brat crossfire
scum cares it's so many going on what we
are moving he's moving man you and this
is my destiny brother man
we're gonna find people find oh man
first of all this is always a highlight
of Sundays for me man it's like every
every time I got to work I just look
forward to it I'm like man it's it's
always a great time and it's it's it's
breathtaking to know that there's people
like you guys out there in the community
that really just homed in on exactly
what you guys want to be and you're not
going to change for anything and that's
what I appreciate the most about this
show so I appreciate that but it's a
gaming for tell you everywhere YouTube
and Twitter it's always amazing there
like he said brat podcast Wednesday
night 9 p.m.
crossfire on Fridays at 7 p.m. and
lovely last Ashley Lucca the pretty but
what town she was to do a show
or p.m. in 7:00 p.m. but it's always on
a Saturday so check that out and make
sure you check out the channel for the
videos man put up a lot of videos about
xbox what they need to do this holiday
to win and I think you guys would
definitely enjoy that piece so I
appreciate the invite as always man
always brother shout out till I seen
that video how that thumbnail cookies
I'm ready I'm ready
oh yeah I saw some behind the scenes on
it and I was very funky billion table oh
yeah it was very sleep see listen let me
tell you something man this man kognito
it's like the bane of my existence at 6
o'clock in the morning because I don't
get a chance to see this man enough and
we don't get a chance to talk so I'll be
getting ready to lie down and go to bed
then I'll go check the iron Lords
discord and there i see cosmo I know
it's for our own cause you can't come at
me bro
good they changed a nails to save the
truck and stuff with a super check they
all not tryna get you to 400 boy yes I'm
glad I'm glad you know I'll wear the
trucker I'm glad we can get to 400 I
might have had to leave the podcast out
water it will get that going on to
probably be in the next month I don't
know pay for this van shipping you can
find me on Twitter
hello at its I ope you can find me on
youtube a gaming addict you can find me
at the glass door casing that good glass
and go put keys knees it first thing was
okay I need something big enough to hold
knees he go the guy's gonna look at you
say oh you're nailing your knees to King
huh
I knew about appreciate gaming for
taking them kids news giving us that
exclusive respective on his challenge we
are gonna have a surprise for you guys
next week it's gonna be a yes we're not
gonna go into what it is right now but
we will be debuting in next week
surprise next week tune in for that baby
Lord sovereign out here with the logic
in the bars wicked if I'm people friends
what you got going on sir well I'm gonna
work move these two gentlemen are
brothers to the realm is oil they come
through slapping balls both of them so
appreciate it thank you
yeah at Lord's table IOP and rent on PSN
and Xbox one
oh my like does to you right leg people
in the bushes on Assassin's Creed I
finished the main campaign I'm into the
DLC are the DLC is fantastic so I can't
wait to get into that and what else I
think I'll be getting on that the
spiciest of be talk the spiciest of
delay talk was it the goof the spicy of
goofy talk squares now is no longer
there oh man first you can find me this
week with a new Kos thank you for all
the support of Cara um I didn't know
what to expect to be honest with you
three weeks out after news doing reveal
after reveal that the PlayStation 5 demo
that was beautiful to see that the Xbox
show that was fantastic
and I was talking man you know cog in
the background
like yo what's gonna happen like I
really didn't know I really really
didn't know if I lost the audience or
whatever but you guys supports crazy
that was absolutely nuts I think that is
probably one of my best performing
videos yes and I don't know sometimes
you got to take a step back in order to
have perspective on things
um I want to give a shout out to kids
move yo dude you're doing things that
I'm not even thinking about doing I'm
not trying to do and God bless on you
you know and thank you for giving me
some of the funniest moments ever seen
in my own right thanks like really
gaming for tape I really love when you
come on because you give that balance to
to to the background I mean a lot of
dudes don't use common sense when it
comes to the stuff but you see it you
live it you see who comes every cast
you're on you're the logic bones yeah
like yeah I got a shout out for Taylor
be like so he's such a breath of fresh
air even when we disagree like I I like
his perspectives or he lets you see
things on from other perspectives
sometimes yeah he knows he knows he cuz
he's there on the front line cook
literally on the front line to be honest
with you said I know the situation is
hard at this period of time right now
for you what's going on
but we definitely gonna make it out of
this brother of I salute you definitely
for coming through and to the team to
the team three thousand subscribers to
the team thousand not to mention you
know we appreciate all this the that's
joined the realm you know we got almost
like 40 or 50 of them oh we got
something new if you join the room we
got something
we'll be announcing it next week yes
what look at Twitter cuz me and King I
don't I have to check my external hard
drive my external graphics are not the
external capture device I have right
working by Tuesday's main King will
start streaming uh the ways out that day
Oh
what if it is there's time I gotta get
some before you leave this road yourself
mad dirty no but this is really for me
okay this is really for me there's
usually every week I watched the last
word usually every week I swear I think
I'm probably one of the most religious
dudes there watch it if I don't watch a
lot I'm definitely watching the late at
night I've been so obsessed with with
Odyssey yes that out and I haven't been
playing destiny all.we I've been ducking
mind my team all week long be honest
what you've been ducking the hell
winters it goes away get your book I
gotta put at the post door to the like
look I did it like oh but the thing is
this right I really like the support and
I was I was watching something and then
it popped up on my YouTube and I looked
up and I said oh my god I miss my man
show I said oh no I definitely saw right
now I thought for this is my throw
behind going right upstairs to watch the
last work out stay out the Forte it's
out to kiss wolf again I cannot stress
enough you I am so proud to wear this
shirt Lord's the game with dotnet you
know I'm saying a passion project from
the game is you're gonna say and just to
see what we're doing I am so proud again
I know it's a little thing but for us
you know to be respected by your peers
in journalism is a huge deal so again I
cannot detain man out today
dizzy I've seen you in there I seen Jean
in there you know I'm saying shot the
rage virus
everybody froze undead Lord Bach moved
out here moving I gotta shout him out
he's got a great piece too
please go to the Lords of gaming that
Nick check out these articles check out
the tech stuff check out the the must
read who check out the entertainment we
got a TV now we out here man we're doing
a lot of things and then please support
the room that's all shout the Lord
Hector you write shout the Lord macho if
you yo you and you on yours
y'all day in doing a pandemic and y'all
split apart amazing article amazing
go on how he's been dealing with his
personal situation and just real gamer
talk so that's all I got man everybody
enjoy your Sunday I know it's a long one
we had a lot of fun next week's gonna be
super lit y'all going like what we got
to talk about trust me and they'll know
everybody's pigs it won't be PlayStation
faster
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]